hi this is a alt shift X live stream to
talk about the season finale of House of
the Dragon episode 10 The Black Queen
we're going to talk all about the
episode we're going to answer your
questions we are not going to spoil
future episodes
and after this live stream there's going
to be a shorter explained video later on
what did you think of the episode what
did you think of the season finale
the previous episode focused on the
greens on Alison's family as they
crowned aegon as king and this episode
focuses on Rainier's family as rhaenyra
is crowned queen setting up the big
conflict between these two sides for the
iron throne
and we had our first Royal casualty in
this war we had the death of rhaenyra's
son lucerus valerion and his dragon arax
killed by the Monstrous Vega and amond
Targaryen and it included a very
surprising change from the books here
because here in the show
amond didn't mean to kill arax and
luceris Vega just did it like aemond was
not fully in control of his dragon
and aemond was like oh no oops I killed
the Prince this was really bad but he
didn't like mean to do it
that's an interesting change
we also had Rainier giving birth to a
stillborn baby a daughter named visenya
in the books at least
and that was sad that was tragic
rhaenyra lost a lot this episode and
when she finds out about the death of
her son at the end of this episode she
gives us a classic uh Targaryen vengeful
look is it just me or does that look
just like Daenerys in uh in season eight
when Daenerys lost misandai
and Daenerys had this moment of being
like okay I'm a villain now I got I got
we got we got some very similar looks
from Daenerys in Game of Thrones so it
is ominous
it is ominous to see a similar look from
Rainier what it what's gonna follow from
her
we also had yeah the return of the sea
snake call this valarion the Lord of
driftmark there was a whole succession
crisis fought in corliss's absence
recently
um it was it was thought that callers
might die of a fever after a wound he
took but Corliss is back and we had a
nice scene with raineys and Corliss
talking about
his Ambitions and their political
attitude and Carlos was saying that ah
you know you know what you're right
you're correct like I have been too
determined to get thrown I've been too
power hungry that has gotten a bunch of
our family killed so let's just chill
let's just retire to high tide and just
be with our grandchildren and just chill
but then rhaenys was like no you idiot
like it's too late like there's a war
now and rangiora is the best hope at
some kind of peace and Justice and the
the best way to protect our
grandchildren at this point is to
participate in this war you idiot is
kind of what rainy says she's nicer
about it
so that was interesting
um and we had Rainier's coronation her
sort of impromptu coronation I thought
it was a really nice contrast how in the
previous episode when the greens were
crowning aegon it was like this huge
event that they had planned and they did
all this conniving and running around
and lying and cheating and stealing in
order to get aegon to the coronation and
they have the huge crowd and they have
the septon and they have the sword and
they have all the things
um and it's all sort of fake and corrupt
last episode but in this episode the
coronation of rhaenyra is just sort of
this natural impromptu thing that
happens like after The Cremation of her
stillborn daughter and it's this moment
of grief that sort of just turns into
her coronation because Eric Cargill
turns up he stole viserys's Crown from
the greens and he defected from the
greens and came to support rhaenyra and
brought the crown and so they have this
impromptu coronation and that just
happens naturally and everyone kneels to
her and it's this very different
situation compared to the greens
coronation of aegon
um
just just seeing like Rainier is
leadership style is interesting
comparing that to aegon I mean aegon
aegon Alison's son doesn't really have
much of a leadership style at all he he
has no interest in being a leader but
rhaenyra is actually trying to be a
politician and she has quite a like like
I think we see a lot of her sort of
uncertainty I mean look at her look at
the way she's holding her hands here
there's a lot of hand acting in House of
the Dragon like Alison is the most
prominent but there are many many
characters who
um show their anxiety by sort of ringing
their hands all the time and we see that
vulnerability in Rainier and another
surprising moment uh was Daemon choking
Rainier
a lot of people upset about this bit
um
it's it's pretty consistent with what
we've seen of Daemon so far I think
um Daemon has always been a violent
person uh Daemon killed his previous
wife with a rock Raya Royce
um Daemon I mean the in the first
episode Daemon like assaults all of
those common people and takes great joy
in mutilating these random peasants who
supposedly are criminals
um Daemon you know takes great joy in
war Daemon like beat that messenger
really badly there's innocent messenger
just because he didn't like the message
like whenever Daemon is upset whenever
he feels insecure he hurts people
innocent people and and in this episode
that includes Rainier so
daemon's not a good person Demon's
horrible Demon's violent and cruel and
um it's going to be really difficult for
rhaenyra dealing with him
in this episode Daemon is really Keen
for war Daemon
is very keen to go fly the dragons and
rally the soldiers and shed some blood
to take the throne partly I think that's
like his grief and anger over the death
of viserys and you know anger at the
Injustice of Alison and aegon taking the
throne I mean it's funny that aegon's
daemon's immediate reaction when he
finds out that aegon has taken the
throne he says that [ __ ] of a queen
murdered my brother and stole his throne
and it's not true that you know Alison
didn't murder viserys but that's the
first thing Daemon goes to because he
doesn't know how to feel grief but he
does know how to feel anger and he does
know how to do violent Vengeance so that
is the emotion that he turns to
whereas rhaenyra you know the the shock
and anger of finding out and the grief
of finding out the viserys is dead and
her throne has been stolen that shock
induces a early labor for her and leads
to this horrible
um birth of the stillborn baby and in
that whole situation but you know she
has this totally opposite reaction uh to
Daemon and while rhaenyra is like
screaming through the halls and like
everyone in the war council can hear her
screaming Daemon is just ignoring her
and focusing on the war that he's trying
to start he ignores his his his wife in
her dangerous labor and focuses on the
war that he wants to start
it's that bit is also quite different in
the books in the books uh rhaenyra's
labor here lasts for days and rhaenyra
is not only like screaming she's she's
screaming
she's screaming in Anger at Allison as
well like in the books uh Rainier says
um
where's the description she's saying
that like
she's she's screaming curses against
Allison
and she's like swearing to get a revenge
on Alison
um while she's giving birth
um just like Alison was made more sort
of you know wanting piece in the
previous episode rhaenyra also is
changed in this episode compared to the
books to be more peaceful they're
definitely like emphasizing this idea in
the show that you know Alison and
rhaenyra mostly just want everyone to
get along it's all these like power
hungry men who with all of their
ambition and their desire for war that
are pushing this conflict whereas in the
book at least so far Allison Genera are
like both equally Keen for conflict
mostly as it's described in the books I
think we might see that change like I
think that in the show we're starting
with a more peaceful allisoner and I
imagine we might see them become more
Extreme as they go on and I think and I
think we saw that with Rainier's face at
the end of this episode I think you know
Rainier might not be quite as easy give
a piece now that her son has been killed
anyway let's answer some of your
questions thanks for the Super Chat from
Nelly who says we finally got to see
Storm's end yeah I was really happy with
how they did Storm's end um so Storm's
end is the castle of house Baratheon
we've seen Stannis hang out here
um and Daenerys hang out here in the
original Game of Thrones show we've
never seen the exterior well no sorry
yeah that's that's Dragonstone Storm's
end we have never seen in Game of
Thrones
um we saw like outside of Storm's end
but this is the first time that we're
properly seeing Storm's end in any of
the shows and and it's quite faithful to
how it's described in the books like it
it describes this big giant like central
tower in the castle like thrust up
towards the sky and it's sort of
symbolically a big middle finger to God
because Storm's end was built in in like
Defiance of the storm Gods who kept
tearing down
um the the castle of uh the defiant
jiren God's grief yeah jiren God's grave
kept rebuilding his castles and so you
know the fact that his castle is still
standing even after the gods kept trying
to tear it down it's like this act of
defiance and I really like how it looks
they have they have made it that like it
it's almost on like a little island
that's just out thrust from the land
surrounded by sea which is reminiscent
of Pike the uh Greyjoy Castle
yeah like luceros arrived in Storm's end
and I loved the shot where he arrives
and then he's like oh no God damn
balerion the black goddamn Vega is there
the largest living Dragon uh and I think
that the terror of that moment was
really well captured by Vega like coming
into view with the Thunder and the storm
clouds that was that was very well done
and luceris really should have like you
know turned 360 degrees and walked
walked out of there uh is what he should
have done but he bravely continued to
deliver his message from rhaenyra trying
to get Lord baratheon's support but he
finds that aemond is already there
aemond and the greens have the same idea
so they already arrived to say hey
baross barathe and you should side with
us
and the irony of this is that
rhaenyra sent Luke to Storm's end
because she thought that Storm's end and
Lord Boris Baratheon would be the easy
task she sent uh her Elder son Jace to
go to the Eerie and then to Winterfell
to try and get the support of the Aarons
and the Starks
um but then Luke she was like well we'll
give you the easy job because Storm's
end is nearby and we're pretty sure the
baratheons will support us it won't be a
problem but they're wrong because the
thing is
um boromand Baratheon was the previous
Lord of Storm's end this guy this is
Barham and Baratheon and he we saw him
in episode one saying hey uh rainey's
Targaryen you're really cool because
like he is the uncle of rainy Targaryen
um and so the baratheons or at least
Borum and Baratheon has always been like
friendly with rhaenys and with the
blacks in general we saw borrowment
again uh in episode four
but rhaenyra made the mistake like now
that boromand is dead and his son boros
has taken over rhaenyra wrongly assumed
that boros would also be friendly but
boros is not in the books it's partly
about gender with boros like in the
books boros is like yeah well you know
like you know maybe rhaenyra was
supposedly the air at some point but
aegon is a son and you know sons are
better than daughters and you know the
sons are the rightful heirs so it's
partly because aegon is a son that boros
decides to support him but also it's a
marriage pact so like they mention it in
the episode that aemond is going to
marry one of boros's daughters it's a
little bit like you know uh Rob promises
to marry one of Lord Walder Frey's
daughters in Game of Thrones
so aimond is like yeah I'll marry one of
your daughters and in the books it
that's like a whole thing like we see
some of the daughters in this episode
there's like four Baratheon daughters
we see aemond like talking to one of
them so it looks like this is the
daughter that amond has chosen to marry
um but in the books it says that amond
is offered four of four daughters and he
gets to choose which daughter he wants
to marry and amond kisses each of boros
baratheon's daughters in turn because he
wants to try before he buys
there's some even more gross line in the
book about like he he wanted to taste
the nectar of each daughter's kiss
before he chose which one he wanted to
marry but anyway like you know because
amond like you know Prince aemond
Targaryen is offering to marry one of
his daughters that's another reason why
boros decides to side with the greens
instead of with rhaenyra
the book says that like while uh Lord
Borum and Baratheon was like very like
reliable and and consistent boros was
like as wild and changeable as the storm
boros is like more fickle than
borrowment and um that's part of why he
you know takes a different side as well
but another detail that's different in
the books is that like in in in the show
like aemond says hey Luke you cut out my
eye so I'm gonna force you to give me
one of your eyes which I'm pretty sure
is um pretty sure that's a line from
It's Always Sunny but um
but aemond is saying like you owe me and
I and then boros is like I don't want
you guys to fight in my hall so get out
of here like I don't want I don't want
this to happen in my hall so they go
outside and then aemon pursues on Vega
but in the books
amond almost didn't go after Luke but
then one of uh the daughters of boros
Baratheon
uh insulted Eamonn one of one of boros's
daughters said hey Eamonn did that kid
take one of your eyes or did he take one
of your balls you wuss like the the
daughter calls aymond a wuss and so
Eamonn basically gets like bullied uh
and insulted and because his pride is
wounded he then goes after Luke
so it's interesting that there was like
you know there were other people
involved in amon's decision to go after
Luke
but yeah it is really interesting that
you know after this Pursuit
um both Luke and Eamonn struggle to
control their dragons like we we hear
them saying the commands
um and then
and then Eamonn and Luca both shocked
when their dragons
don't follow their orders because araks
shoots flame at Vega without Luke's
wanting him to
um and
then vegar kills arax and Luke
um
and they're both shouting no the whole
time and that's a really interesting and
surprising change the failure to control
the dragon I mean you know it does have
precedent because like you know Daenerys
struggles to control drogon in both the
show and the book especially in the book
I mean something to keep in mind is that
like the the whole like Dragon
controlling uh infrastructure is is gone
since valyria blew up like in the books
they mentioned that the ancient
valyrians had like Dragon horns
that they could use like a magic dragon
horns that could bind dragons to their
will and that was something that they
used to control dragons better
um there's a lot more knowledge about
dragons that has been lost
and also there's the fact that you know
amond and Luke are very young they're
just kids they haven't got enough uh
Pokemon gym badges in order to control
their dragons like vegar is this ancient
giant monster she is so much more
powerful I don't know if amond has like
the willpower and the experience to
control Vega properly and there's lots
of questions about the sort of potential
psychic link between a dragon and the
rider like does the dragon sense The
Writer's desires uh and and interpret
how to behave
um does the dragon's personality affect
the writer's personality like does the
warlike powerful angry energy of Vega
affect amon's decision making
and what does aemond do afterwards like
something that the kosher on a Ryan
condle
be hinted at in the inside the episode
is that you know aemond has now
accidentally killed lucerus and now he
has the choice of like when he comes
home to King's Landing and says
um
so here's the thing
um mum
um I killed a prince whoops it was an
accident I didn't want to whoops sorry
is he gonna do that or is he gonna say
hey I'm a badass and I decided to kill
Luke because this is a war and we've got
to win and I'm so badass you know and I
think the implication is that amont is
gonna is going to do the ladder he's
going to claim that he did it
deliberately
um and that sort of fits with what the
books say kind of because like the books
are written by the historians
the book Fire and Blood the the maesters
don't really know exactly what happened
um like it's described in the book that
you know the people on the ground in
Storm's end like they saw like a burst
of fire in the storm clouds above and
like they saw that something was
happening but they didn't know exactly
what happened but they certainly don't
know the details of like you know
whether aemon did this on purpose or not
but if aemon says that yeah I did this
deliberately then that's what the
history books will think
um and so it's sort of like you know is
aemond really a villainous monster or
does he just sort of become a villainous
monster because he seems that way like
because he claims responsibility for
killing Luke he has to act like a bad
guy now I mean remember that kin slaying
is really bad like killing your
relatives is considered one of the most
evil crimes in this world
um and Luke is aemon's nephew or half
nephew so he is now amond the kin Slayer
so it's like you know it kind of forces
him into a villainous role I think
um we also saw something interesting
which was Daemon coming and visiting the
dragon Verma Thor this is the first time
we've seen the dragon Verma Thor and
Verma Thor was the dragon of King
jiharis who was the king before viserys
uh this fella his Dragon was Verma Thor
so Verma Thor is one of the biggest and
oldest dragons not as big or old as Vega
but certain only a powerful Dragon and
we had this whole Dragon discussion at
daemon's war council where they were
counting
um they were counting which Dragon like
which side has the most dragons
um and basically the situation is the
the greens aegon and Alison they have
more they have bigger armies they have
stronger allies with like the high
towers and the reach and the tyrells
um and the Lannisters are on their side
um so they've got more soldiers but the
blacks rhaenyra's side have more dragons
like the greens amond has Vega which is
the most powerful Dragon and they also
have
aegon's Dragon Sunfire and Helena's
Dragon dream fire
but the blacks like rhaenyra has a
dragon Daemon has a dragon
rhaenys has a dragon Jace Luke R.I.P
Luke
and Baylor have dragons and then there's
these wild dragons so they mentioned
that there's like Verma Thor jeheris's
old Dragon then there's Silver Wing
which was the dragon of jeheris's Queen
alisane and there's also sea smoke who
is Leno's dragon and it remains to be
seen if sea smoke can even be claimed by
anyone else since Lane ore is secretly
still alive
and and Daemon also mentions that there
are wild dragons on Dragonstone there's
a few of those
um and you know there's also like you
know the books mentioned that uh aegon
and Helena's children young children
have hatchlings and there's several
other dragons that will appear later so
so you know there's about there's a few
dragons but the point is that the blacks
have more dragons whereas the greens
have a bigger Army so there's this whole
sort of tactical strategic discussion of
how do we leverage this advantage
and we had one of the Lords at the
council saying hey like let's just use
the dragons let's go to King's Landing
and burn them and defeat the grains
right now and Daenerys said well I don't
want to be the queen of ashes and Bone
when you use dragons innocent people die
as we saw in the previous episode with
rhaenys and melis and this mirrors the
issues that Daenerys had in Game of
Thrones season 7 and 8 when when
Daenerys was like I want to attack
King's Landing with dragons and Tyrion
was saying you probably shouldn't do
that because lots of innocent people
will die so
Rainier is facing a similar issue
um and she's trying not to kill too many
innocent people and Daemon also made the
point that like with with Dragons it's
really hard for just a human to kill a
dragon like you can get lucky with a
scorpion bolt or an arrow
um but dragons are mostly mostly
impervious to like most human weapons
the best way to kill a dragon is with
another dragon and so the blacks are
worried about Vega like like the most
powerful dragons on the on Rainier's
side uh you know probably caraxi's is
probably number one and then like Cyrax
and melis uh but vegar is stronger than
any of them so there's going to be
there's a lot of concern about potential
dragon battles here and potentially
recruit like getting some riders for
these unclaimed dragons to try and get
even more of an advantage
Silva says in your vids it's maybe more
appropriate to say this is different
from the book instead of this is a
change from the book as the show deals
with the idea that history books may not
reflect reality
says Silva
um
yeah one of the other change one of the
other uh differences from the book Is
How They did something with Orwell in
the books that I enjoyed in the books
like we have this piece offering that
Otto brings from Alison saying hey
rhaenyra let's not have a war you should
just surrender and then everything will
be cool beans and I thought it was funny
that um Otto offers a different peace
deal than what Alison told him to in the
previous episode like remember there was
that whole thing last episode about like
capturing aegon so that the so that
Alison could set the terms and Alison
was like we are not going to kill
rhaenyra we're going to offer her a
decent piece uh decent peace terms that
she can accept without shame and Ellison
says like you know rainy era must not
return Alison said and so the
implication of Alison's words was that
she was gonna suggest for rhaenyra to be
exiled for a nearer to leave and go to
the east because you know that's kind of
of the only place to go from Westeros
um
and so it's weird to me that Otto in
this episode said oh no we're gonna like
make uh we're gonna confirm you guys can
have Dragonstone what was his exact
wording
he said that like
yeah he he said that your son's with
Daemon
viserys and aegon can be given places at
court luceris will be the heir to drift
mark
yeah your possession of Dragonstone
yeah so it's interesting to me that in
this episode
Otto said you can stay at Dragonstone
whereas in the previous episode Alison
was saying Rainier should like leave
is is the implication I don't know like
given that that so much of last episode
was about Alison trying to set the terms
of the peace deal it's weird to me that
Otto sort of offers a different base
deal than what Alison was saying
it seems like Allison should have come
personally like we have Otto give
Rainier this page that he tore out of
that book about nymeria like I remember
previously when Alison and Rainier
we're in the godswood reading that book
and then Rainier tore the page out of
the book and it's sort of this symbol of
like oh rhaenyra is so rebellious but
Alison gives that page back to Rainier
and now as a way of saying hey like
remember when we were friends when we
were kids like let's be friends again
let's make peace
um which is a nice little symbol but it
just makes me think why didn't Ellison
come in person like I guess she's the
queen she's a more you know they don't
want to risk her or whatever but you
know since Alison no longer trusts
Otto
like you know Allison said our hearts
were never won
why does Allison trust Otto to deliver
these terms why doesn't Ellison just go
herself
why doesn't she just like you know why
doesn't she just get aegon to fly her to
Dragonstone on Sunfire and and she and
aegon can present the terms
it's weird to me Allison's Trust of Otto
In This Moment
anyway uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Presta who says do you see rhaenyra as
being indecisive or passive like her
father viserys I mean she was reluctant
to take action at First In This Moment
like all of the men were saying let's
prepare for war and Rainier was saying
let's not do anything just yet I want to
like suss out the situation I want to
talk to our potential allies and Rainier
definitely was like embodying viserys's
Legacy in this episode like she was
saying that you know my job is to keep
Unity my job is to keep the peace
um and so yeah she was definitely
consciously like vibing viserys right
now and I wonder if that might change
now that Luke is dead and now that
Rainier is angry I think I think that
might possibly change
um
and you know she's wearing viserys's
Crown as well which is like a visual
symbol of like how she is imitating
viserys
um and viserys's desire for peace so you
know we'll we'll see if we'll see if
Rainier are manages to to keep any kind
of peace and unity uh thanks for the
donation from fathers of daughters who
says Bradley of house Heinz is the love
of my life thanks father
Ethan says please do a more a [ __ ]
Abridged that's a show on the old drift
X YouTube channel Daniel says love how
the dragons are going to live up to
their reputation as Fantastical nukes
that can't be controlled no matter how
many gym badges one has yeah I mean the
the key thing with the dragons is that
previously
viserys said that the idea that we
control the dragons is an illusion and
he also suggests that dragons are what
destroyed valyria which is not what the
books say exactly but that's an
interesting suggestion but yeah like
viserys told us in episode one that the
dragons are hard to control and I think
that's especially true when
the they're being written by children
I mean look personally I blame the
parents for this whole situation it was
the parents who gave the kids swords and
trained them to fight and told them to
see each other as enemies like letting
the children have dragons at the at this
tender young age is is crazy so it's not
shocking that This Disaster happened one
of the other details in the books is
that it says that you know Luke valerion
appears to have been killed by aemond
and vegar but there are some Legends
among the common folk that apparently
luceris actually secretly survived this
attack and became a simple-minded Fisher
folk hanging out in a fishing Village
and lived to a ripe old age
probably not true
probably not true I mean there are
several pieces of Luke falling from 5000
feet right now but um there is a legend
that Luke is is uh actually still alive
thanks for the Super Chat from Ariel who
says that birth scene actually made me
cringe and shed tears anyone who's had a
baby can probably relate yeah that was
intense that was visceral there was a
lot of emotions in that scene
um they described it in the inside the
episode as rhaenyra was at war with her
body because this was a premature of
birth this was a stillborn birth this
was not meant to happen and Rainier has
always had a complicated relationship
like with her gender and and feeling
sort of frustrated by her body I mean
remember earlier in the show rhaenyra
said I don't want to be trapped in a
tower making babies all day and yet this
is rhaenyra's sixth childbirth
um so you know she said she didn't want
to be married this is her second
marriage that she's in and so like
somehow she she has been railroaded into
this you know gender role that she was
never quite wanting to have but yeah she
had this
traumatic intense birth scene and um the
baby did not come out looking great I
don't you know I don't know exactly what
it should look like a month premature
but in the books it says that Rainier is
stillborn baby the daughter called
vicenya in the in the books
uh this baby is a is scaly and has a
tail it's it's got like Dragon features
in the books supposedly mushroom says
that the baby comes out looking like a
dragon which is similar to Daenerys
Daenerys in Game of Thrones
um gives birth to a baby that she is
told was all like
rotted and dragony and full of grave
worms
so it's interesting that that happened
again with Rainier and like sometimes
that you know sometimes that seems
connected to Magic like it was really
interesting that you know Rainier while
she was
um birthing the stillborn we got all
these like tiny flashes of cyrax's face
like we saw these images of rhaenyra's
dragon flashing on screen while she was
giving birth to this stillborn
um which suggests that there's like a
connection between like the the blood of
the Dragon that's in the targaryens
um and the weird stillbirths that happen
with them sometime uh you could also
connect it to Daemon like you know maybe
since you know Demon's evil
um might be connected to the uh dragon
features like the the reproductive
failure of their Union that's something
that comes up sometimes in the books but
yeah this is something that happens with
Targaryen sometimes
um
JS says Daemon grabbing rhaenyra was
totally messed up and out of character
why are the writers being so dull yeah a
lot of strong reactions to Daemon
grabbing Rainier I I think that it is
consistent with what we've seen of
Daemon he has hurt a lot of innocent
people when he feels emotional
um he you know killed his previous wife
with a rock
I'm not I don't think it's inconsistent
for Daemon to hurt rhaenyra I think
hurting people is his [ __ ] up way of
dealing with his emotions
um it was interesting the context of
this moment though wasn't it because the
what what sparked Daemon
um
to attack Rainier like that was that
rhaenyra brought up aegon the
conqueror's dream because remember that
viserys told rhaenyra that like hey
there is a prophecy made by aegon the
Conqueror that the targaryens must be in
charge and must be leading a unified
Westeros in order to defeat the White
Walkers and rhaenyra assumed that Daemon
knew this like she just talked about oh
you know the song of ice and fire like
don't you know about the Song of Ice and
Fire
and Daemon was so angry that he like
finds out that rhaenyra knows this
important thing that he doesn't and
that's part of why he chokes her
um
so really interesting that Daemon you
know Daemon didn't know that and I think
that
it's it's the same as like
um you know what'd she say she said yeah
he never told you it's the same as how
viserys never made Dame on hand of the
king like Daemon was saying to viserys
like if you trust me and if you love me
as your brother you should make me
handle the king you should include me on
the council you should make me your Heir
like that was daemon's issue early in
this season
um and now this is just another example
to Daemon of like oh and also there was
this big prophecy that viserys never
told me about so that's another way that
my brother didn't love me and my brother
rejected me that's how Daemon feels
about it
um
and yeah I mean I I feel like viserys
maybe should have told Daemon about the
prophecy maybe Daemon might have taken
the prophecy seriously because we know
that Daemon you know Daemon read all
those uh valyria books in pentos like
Daemon is really interested in Valyrian
history and tradition and you know he he
wore that like he did that traditional
Valyrian wedding in and outfit and
ceremony with Rainier so like given that
he's interested in like law and history
and Valyrian
Heritage I think that Daemon would have
been really interested in Akon's
prophecy and since the prophecy is all
about Targaryen Unity I don't know maybe
it would have been a good idea for
viserys to tell Daemon about the
prophecy but I mean Daemon does also say
in this scene like Daemon says my
brother was a slave to his Omens and
poor tents anything to make his feckless
Reign appear to have purpose so Daemon
is that Daemon does know that viserys
has some interest in Prophecy like maybe
Damon knew about viserys's dream that he
would have a son that he was mentioned
in the earlier Seasons
um but Daemon didn't know about the Song
of Ice and Fire prophecy in particular
um but yeah it's interesting that Daemon
is so negative about viserys's
prophecies maybe that's just his
immediate reaction here
uh anyway uh thanks for the Super Chat
from boopington oh well another another
thing I would say about the prophecy is
that you know a big part of why rhaenyra
is constantly urging for peace and unity
right now a big part of why Rainier is
trying to prevent War right now is
because she is mindful of that prophecy
and she's mindful of that responsibility
and it's tied up with you know it's not
just about aegon and white walkers it's
about her father viserys and his
grandfather Harris who had peaceful
Realms wearing that particular Golden
Crown and she wants to continue that
peaceful Legacy
thanks for the Super Chat from
boopington who says the only reason
amond didn't want Luke did was because
he wanted to carve out Luke's eye
something tells me he was evil already
what yeah I may have pre I may have
earlier overstated
um amond you know amond is not a super
innocent guy he was threatening to cut
out a child's eye uh just before so yeah
he was he was already a dick but like I
think it's important that aemond you
know aemond looks like a villain right
like aemond looks like a bad dude
because he's got a scar he's got the eye
patch and he's a warrior and he's got a
he's just got that face you know he
looks like a baddie
um but he doesn't do anything evil up
until now oh well and even you know even
now like he didn't mean to kill Luke
um I mean Daemon has murdered a lot of
innocent people aemond has not murdered
any innocent people
they're like deliberately like the what
like some of the worst things that
aemond has done is like
you know I'm I mean you could blame
amond for escalating the brawl with the
other children like in the fight where
aemon's eye was cut out when he was a
kid you could blame aemond for
escalating that conflict but you know he
didn't strike the first blow
um
you also could say that amond you know
when he made that speech at the Last
Supper when he said you know you strong
boys are so strong like he was
deliberately trying to you know
uh stir some [ __ ] up and create conflict
then but amond is not a killer
not deliberately anyway
um so you know he he's a dick but like
you could argue that he's he's kind of
right to be a dick in that like he had
his eye cut out and he wants Justice for
that he never got Justice for his
mutilation and that's a you know that
that is a very real grievance so you
know amod is not a good guy but I think
that he has some understandable
motivations and some understandable
bitterness and it's going to be really
interesting in the next season you know
what kind of person he is
because now he's got to deal with you
know he's a kinslayer now as far as the
world is concerned he deliberately
murdered his nephew and that's going to
be a uh it's gonna be a whole issue
in the books there's a character called
crowfood Amber and he also has a stone
in in the place of his missing eye in
his empty eye socket he keeps a bit of
dragonglass
food umber because the crows ate his
eyeball he was like lying wounded on a
battlefield and then a crow came along
and ate his eyeball while he was like
too wounded to stop it but then he ate
the crow you know yeah no no no he
didn't eat the crow the crow ate his
eyeball and that's why he's called Crow
food and then he keeps a chunk of
obsidian in his eye socket you know
pretty pretty metal pretty anime uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Corbin
who says do you think the intro for
season two will change to a more
traditional Game of Thrones map overview
I feel like Westeros will have a lot of
moving Parts going forward yeah so I
mean
for season one we had this like
bloodline family tree which made some
sense because the family tree was always
changing like we like most of the
characters in this show were born during
this season you know all of rhaenyra's
children and
um Alison's children and grandchildren
like Alison became a grandmother in the
course of this first season which is a
pretty unusual thing to happen uh like
this
um so you know since the family tree was
constantly shifting it kind of made
sense to have this bloodline opening
sequence
um and I don't think it's a spoiler to
say that
um there will be fewer Big Time Skips
from now on in House of the Dragon
um so I I agree with you that it may
make more sense to have a map overview I
mean we had the painted table in this
episode which is the table made by aegon
the Conqueror of Westeros and it seems
to have like a like a it's got an RGB
feature
you know those are you know those gamer
keyboards that have all the the lights
in the keyboard that's what the fainted
table looks like to me it's uh yeah
um and so yeah it looks like you can
like put a candle inside the table and
it's like Hollow or translucent so that
the table lights up that's cool I I
guess the igb broke in the time of Game
of Thrones because it it doesn't have
this feature in uh when Stannis and
Daenerys are using the painted table but
anyway it's it's a glow-in-the-dark
table cool
um and yeah I agree that the map might
make sense uh because like in this
episode they talked about the um
I talked about the various Lords of
Westeros so here's a little political
map of westerosphoria these are all the
great Lords of Westeros the most
powerful Lords in Westeros uh so we
mentioned uh rhaenyra told Jace hey get
on your dragon fly up to Jane Aaron
she's probably gonna support the blacks
rhaenyra because rhaenyra's mother was
an Aaron so their family so she assumes
that the Aarons will support them and
then Jace is going to fly up to the
north and go talk to Craigen Stark Lord
Craig and Stark who was a young man and
they're hoping that he's going to
support them
um
and they talk about you know stocks
never break Oaths they're really
reliable they'll be great
um they don't really mention the iron
ball in this episode I don't think
um but the ironborn I mean
that they might be relevant they're
currently led by Dalton Greyjoy the red
Kraken and he's like 16 years old um and
he loves battle and bloodshed that's why
they call him the red Kraken
um so he's a he's a piece of work and he
might be useful because like there's the
whole ships thing right so like the the
blacks have callus and the valerions who
have the most powerful Fleet in Westeros
um and so the greens are relying on like
the Lannister Fleet of ships but the
Lannister Fleet is not as good as
um the valerion fleet
um but you know the ironborn also have a
really powerful Fleet so they might be
relevant there
um the lord of the reach is currently a
baby called Lionel Tyrell I think his
mother is ruling for him
um and you could argue that Lord Hobart
Hightower is kind of more powerful than
the tyrells are in a lot of ways and
it's assumed that the tyrells in the
high Towers will both be supportive of
aegon and the greens
um the martells and Dawn uh might not be
relevant because Dawn is not part of
Westeros currently dawn has not been
conquered and has not joined the rest of
Westeros Dawn does not respect the
authority of the iron throne
um
and yeah the baratheons uh Rainier
thought that the baratheons would
support her but it now looks like the
baratheons are going to support uh the
greens and aegon Grover Tully they said
something about like um
is very like fickle and changeable so it
will have to remind Grover of of his
loyalties which is kind of different to
how it's described in the books I I
don't think I can say yet I I guess
we'll learn more next season but um
there's some cool stuff going on with
Grover and yes Grover is named after a
muppet and Grover has family members
called ilmo and Kermit
um Sesame Street characters anyway
um so yeah that's the thing thanks for
the Super Chat from Jack who says would
love to see Jimmy Simpson in season two
uh with his eye patch how do you feel
about all the obvious repetitive
dialogue and Converse I did feel like
there was some repetition in this
episode where they sort of kept saying
the same things about like the war
situation and wanting peace and that
yeah I feel like there was some
repetitive dialogue in this episode
thanks for the Super Chat from Nate who
says in the books do the dragons show
any sort of communication or
relationships with each other
that's an interesting question I mean we
we don't get to see much of that sort of
thing because
like
in the time of the main Game of Thrones
books there's only three dragons uh
drogon viserion and rhaegar
um and yeah I don't know I mean they
describe the dragons like flying around
with each other above daenerys's ship
um they describe how you know like
viserion and rhaegar are locked
underneath the Great Pyramid of marine
while Dr I mean drogon has his own sort
of Personality where drogon is like the
more big dangerous one and drogon is the
one who flies around and eats children
and such
um we don't see a whole lot of like
interaction between the dragons I mean I
guess you know there is the moment where
uh viserion kills Quentin Martell in
book five and it sort of seems as though
rhaegar and viserion are sort of closing
in on him from either side and it sort
of looks like they're working together
but no yeah I can't think of examples of
like personality interacting between the
dragons in the books I mean you know
like the the times when there were lots
of dragons interacting like like this
time period in Hot D
um is only described
by the maesters in the history books and
you know we don't get detail like Fire
and Blood is not like a detailed novel
it's only a brief plot summary written
by the maesters so and the maesters
generally don't like dragons and don't
like describing dragons and don't know
much about dragons so the the whole sort
of dragon law thing in the books is
still quite mysterious like how dragons
work is quite mysterious
um and yeah it was Verma Thor that we
saw in um
in Daemon scene and I like how Daemon
was like singing like a Valyrian lullaby
to the dragon to keep vermouth or chill
uh I wonder what the words of the
lullaby were the uh what's his name
David Peterson is the linguist who
created the Valyrian language for Game
of Thrones
um
he can probably offer a translation of
what Daemon was saying in the lullaby
that would be cool
um
El Capitan asks if this dragon is a
match for vegar there is nothing in this
world as powerful as Vega
that there is I mean maybe if a bunch of
other dragons ganged up on Vega then
then maybe but but there is no one
dragon that could likely I mean I mean
maybe if if it's lucky
but Vega outclasses every other Dragon
Adam says where did Harold westerling go
after walking out of the council meeting
yeah so Eric left the greens and came
and joined rain era but Harold
westerling left the greens and has not
shown up
um and I suppose this this is like a
super mild spoiler I don't think it's a
spoiler
um in the books Harold westerling is
literally only mentioned one time ever
in in the entire series
um and it says that Harold westerling uh
exists
um and and then doesn't that's the
entirety of the mention of Harold
wrestling in the books
um so basically everything that Harold
does is everything that Harold does is
made up for the show so book readers we
don't know what what happens with Harold
so it is really interesting that he has
this you know moment of leaving the
council and we don't know where he is or
what he does I I get a lot of Barrister
Vibes with Harold I think it's quite
possible that he'll like turn up later
and there are a few ways that he could
there are a few things that could have
with him but yeah it's not in the books
so we don't know for sure uh desorn says
why is Cyrax the same size now as 20
years ago uh Cyrax should be bigger
Cyrax should be bigger do you think it's
the same here's Cyrax
now
looking pretty big and let's have a look
at Cyrax
previously
this is how Cyrax looked before
I think cyrex has gotten a little bit
bigger
I don't think Cyrax has gotten like
massively bigger but I think Cyrax is
bigger
yeah it's not it's not a huge change
Cyrax certainly should be bigger at this
point
Jenks says rhaenyra just finished saying
how boros is arrogant and then she sends
Luke to him with nothing but a reminder
of his Allegiance makes zero sense yeah
I think we're in Europe probably should
have like thought a bit more about how
to win over these Lords I mean I think
she was she was stuck in that mindset of
like oh like you know Lord boromand was
always supportive of of us so boros will
be supportive as well and you know
Rainier had a lot of other things on her
mind like the death of her father to
think about and the stillborn baby that
just died like you know Rainier might
not have been thinking as much as she
should have I guess
um but yeah I mean I mean usually that's
enough like usually he's sending a
Targaryen on a dragon or a valerion on a
dragon is enough to remind people and
I'm and remember like these Lords or at
least the fathers of these Lords swore
Oaths to support rhaenyra in front of
everyone the king said that rhaenyra is
my Heir so it's like rhaenyra shouldn't
have to go out of her way to convince
these people who already should support
her but but yeah like it would have been
smarter to think a bit more about it and
you can question whether it was a good
idea to send Jace and Luke at all
like Jason Luke are so young that like
they are not politicians really they're
not diplomats they're not
it was a risk to send them I think that
they're sort of relying on the shock and
awe of the Dragons
um
because dragons can be very persuasive
um but you know I mean the greens have
dragons as well so they probably should
have anticipated that the greens might
have the same idea and send their own
dragons so yeah I think it may have been
a mistake to send Jason Luke like that
soda says now that the season is
finished can you review internet
historians redoing the Game of Thrones
finale
since you're the same person
um I haven't seen that video I mean uh
yeah I haven't seen that video uh it
might be fun to like react to other
videos I guess I don't know I don't know
what that video is about uh Ahmed says
speaking of the prophecy this is a wild
guess the sword ice was melted down by
fire to bring oath keeper which
handle has the shape of a lion head uh
yeah so you're talking about like the
sword ice
um which was melted down uh into widow's
whale and oath keeper in season four
episode one
uh so you're saying that sword is the is
the Song of Ice and Fire or is that what
you're saying Ahmed I guess
um
but I think the cat's baller blade is
the one that you know that's what's used
to kill the white walkers in the show
thank you Jesse and thank you Cole who
says is it me or is Kristen Cole
supposed to be the reverse Jamie a man
with honor losing it as opposed to a man
without honor gaining it
yeah I mean there are similarities
between Kristen and Jamie I mean they
both sort of grapple with their Oaths
and while Jaime uh in the books starts
to try to be less [ __ ] Kristen really
seems to be on a downward trajectory
um he he takes his dishonor badly and
just dishonors himself more I you know I
think that like Kristen thinks that he
was
Dishonored by having sex with rhaenyra
but I think what really has Dishonored
Kristen is all of his murders killing
joffre longmeth killing Lyman beesberry
just generally being a hateful
shitsterer
um
I think like one of the interesting
things compare comparing the show in the
books is that in the books Kristen seems
to have a much bigger role I mean
especially in like the earlier books I
think that George kind of
retconned the this part of the history
books a little bit because in like the
earliest mentions it they really pin the
whole war on Kristen like the the early
books make it sound like Kristen caused
this conflict they call Kristen the king
maker
um and in the books it was Kristen Who
convinced aegon hey you should you
should agree to be king in the books
um in the books it was Kristen who found
aegon at the child fighting pit and said
hey aegon you've got to become king or
else Rainier is going to kill you and
that's why you should be king
um and so some characters say that
Kristen is the reason why this conflict
happens and Kristen is the reason why
Akon becomes king it's like a whole
thing whereas they sort of removed
Kristen's influence so that part of the
story in Hot D which is interesting
um and yeah like in the show Kristen it
looks like it might have been an
accident when Kristen killed Lyman like
I don't think Kristen deliberately
killed Lyman it just sort of happened
um whereas in the books it it was a
deliberate Murder by Kristen and and in
the books it seems like Kristen killing
Lyman was like a really conclusive
moment of like okay like we're doing it
like Kristen killing Lyman was like
the point of no return where the greens
were like okay we're doing it um and
Kristen you know had more of a voice at
the Grand Council in the books like he
was arguing like hey we we need a crown
aegon not support Rainier or because
Rainier is such a big [ __ ] [ __ ] who's
going to turn the red keep into a
brothel he says in the books
um
so Kristin has a bigger role in starting
the war in the books
thanks for the Super Chat from Jess who
says the response from the mother of
Lord Tyrell is very funny in the books
if I remember correctly well we'll we'll
get to that lotana says this is all
Otto's fault
yeah I mean one of the sort of tragic
ironies of this whole situation is that
Otto is saying we've got to
kill rhaenyra because otherwise rhaenyra
will kill us and Rick and Daemon is
saying we've got to kill the greens or
else the greens are going to kill us but
neither rhaenyra or Alison want to kill
anyone
um another does aegon particularly like
like like the actual people at the
center of this conflict don't want peace
I do want peace they don't want war and
I think that also and you know to some
extent Daemon like their eagerness
um it's like a game theory thing like if
both sides just agreed to be peaceful
then there'd be no cost but since both
sides assume that the other side will
attack then it becomes in your interests
to attack you know
um
so yeah it's tragic and and the actors
and interviews and stuff have said that
you know if Rainier and Alison could
just sit down in a room without all of
these bloody Lords around then they
probably could sort this out between
themselves you know and that's why I
think it's so unfortunate that it was
Otto who came to deliver the terms Otto
is the last person who either who either
rhonera or Daemon are going to submit to
or agree to you know I thought it was
interesting that after Otto presented
the terms rhaenyra said you know I will
I I will let you know my answer in a few
days kings that King's Landing will have
my answer on the morrow so it sounds
like Rainier like might actually be
considering like agreeing to all those
terms and making peace but now that Luke
is dead there's kind of no going back
from that thanks for the Super Chat from
Alex and from Shadow who says do you
think that the seasons going forward
will be constructed like season one with
five episodes for the younger versions
and then five episodes for the adult
versions uh I don't to spoil anything
but like there's not going to be big
time skips so much Sunkist says the idea
we control the dragons is an illusion uh
Amish says what's up with boros
Baratheon being illiterate yeah so boros
got the letter from rhaenyra and he said
oh where's the bloody maester I come and
get the maester to read this for me
um because yeah boros can't read and
that's actually very common like a lot
of Lords don't read uh it sort of
depends where you are and which which
culture you're in in Westeros
um but yeah many many lords don't read
and they rely on the maces to do it for
them and that's part of why some
characters are like hey maybe we
shouldn't trust the maesters because
like who knows if they're really
um telling the truth about what's in
these letters maybe they want to
manipulate things and there is a whole
theory that the maesters might have
manipulated the greens and the blacks
into into attacking each other
because the maesters don't like the
targaryens and they don't like the
dragons and they don't like the magic
and they want a more stable peaceful
secular world without magic and blood
and fire so
so yeah that's a thing uh thanks Joshua
thanks Jack who says call us seem to be
pretty cool with the vemond murder when
he found out about it yeah I I agree I
agree Jack
um like call us wakes up from this fever
and then rhaenyra says that uh you know
hey by the way
um your friend Daemon killed your
brother vemond and Carlos's reaction is
like oh yeah that's that sounds right he
sort of rolls his eyes and then he says
oh well you know vemond was too
ambitious which is it's a pretty
sanguine reaction to the to the murder
of his brother because it kind of was
murder like Daemon did not have like a
legal right to kill vemond really like
it's not like the king had ordered
vemon's execution when Vermont died
viserys just said like I will have your
tongue for that and then Daemon cut off
his head and said he can keep his tongue
so like it is messed up that Daemon
killed Vermont like that and Carlos is
like oh yeah that's cool my friend
killed my brother whatever like really
and then like callus mentioned that he
believes that rhaenyra killed their son
Lana and I thought it was weird that
rainey's did not correct Corliss because
like rhaenyra told rhaenys previously
that rhaenyra did not kill lanor but
rhaenys does not tell colas that like I
I feel like I feel like it should be a
bigger deal that Rainier has supposedly
killed Lena you know
which incidentally is is also not in the
books like in the books it seems as
though Daemon may have killed Leno
um but the whole thing about Lee not
getting away free is is not even a thing
in the books
another thing that I I liked was that we
got to meet uh bartimus kilterga uh who
is who is the leader of one of the only
surviving Valyrian houses
um
like you know in all of those scenes
when like Corliss and viserys were
saying ah the targaryens and the
valerions are the the last of the
Valyrian houses there are no other
Valyrian houses only the targaryens and
the valerians
uh that's celtegar Erasure because the
celtagas are also a Valyrian house they
are not as powerful as the targaryens
and the valerians they don't have a
great Fleet of ships and they don't have
dragons but the celticas are Valyrian so
it's nice to see The Kilt guys actually
turn up for once because they are one of
they are one of the you know loyal
long-standing allies of the targaryens
yeah crabs in the chat folks crabs in
the chat for house celtica because their
sigil is the crab
uh the celticas have a Valyrian steel ax
in the books which is super cool so yeah
it's nice to see the kilter girls turn
up and they mentioned some of the other
like allies
um of the like the houses in the
crownlands who support the targaryens
and the valerians
that is like the bar emins and the
masses
um and some of those folks who live in
the area around King's Landing and they
are like directly sworn to the iron
throne
uh but in this case they're swearing to
Rainier and and the valerians because
they have like close alliances with
Dragonstone and driftmark
but yeah they are very minor houses so
so the blacks really don't have much of
an army to go up against the greens with
Colleen says did you see daemon's neck
he's right under his ear looks like the
show is giving him grayscale
I don't think that Daemon has grayscale
that would be a weird thing to add I
guess it's possible are you saying his
neck here we have seen in the past that
Daemon appears to have like Burns
on his body which I think probably comes
from the moment when
we saw Daemon get hit by a flaming arrow
on the stepstones previously so I I
think that that flaming arrow burned him
and that's why he has burnt skin I don't
think it's grayscale but hey if they
wanted to do something wild they could I
mean you know grayscale makes people go
mad and turn into stone men zombies
eventually
um so I guess if they wanted to like add
a plot point about like oh no daemon's
going crazy because he's got magic
leprosy watch out like I guess they
could do that but like I think Daemon is
interesting because the reason why he is
a violent [ __ ] is emotional
and understandable so I I don't think
they're going to give him grayscale
I I really think that crackers crab
feeder having grayscale it was just uh
cosmetic decision to make him look
spooky and I think that it worked
thanks for the Super Chat from Jinx who
says are we to assume that amond knew
that arax was acting out against Luke's
wishes did he hear Luke berating araks
that context is important okay I mean
let's yeah let's think about that so
what what happened
was that aemond God on Vega and flew
after Luke who was flying on his dragon
arax
and I mean right right away my question
is like amond what is your plan like
what is aemon's plan here what does he
want to happen like it's pretty clear
that aemond did not want to kill Luke
because that is like a big escalation
um and his you know Alison and Otto are
going to be pierced he could start a war
like he killed a prince that's a big
deal
so Eamon did not want to kill Luke he
just wanted to like scare Luke he just
wanted to bully him I mean we saw aemond
like laughing maniacally
um which I thought was fun like he was
he was like the bad guy in a movie like
the he was like The Jock who like
bullies the you know like he's the he's
the big bad guy big tough guy bullying
the small kid
um and you know I think that's
consistent with like aemon's character
because you know aemond himself used to
be the the smaller bullied kid and we
saw him you know have that power Rush
um
in episode 7 when when he was all of a
sudden like he had all this power and he
was
um just full of like ego
um and that gave him this sort of
violent confidence in this sort of like
wanting to get revenge on people you
know Luke had bullied him with that you
know pink dread when he was a kid and I
think that you know having Vega has
really changed who amond is like he's
suddenly powerful and he's suddenly
confident but he also feels wronged and
he also feels better still which is a
dangerous combination right because
amond is powerful
but still feels like he's not respected
enough and like aemond feels like he has
the right to hurt people because of how
he was hurt even though he is no longer
the underdog
like he is no longer the underdog but he
still feels like an underdog and so he
feels like he's justified in like
bullying and attacking people even
though he's no longer the underdog you
know um anyway but but yeah like it's
obviously wildly irresponsible to be
chasing a prince through a storm on Vega
like Vega is the biggest nuclear Arsenal
in the world like you don't fire nukes
at someone as a prank even if the nukes
are diffused you know even if you don't
plan to blow up the nukes like you
should not
fire missiles at people you should not
get your like nuclear submarine and and
use it to buzz your friends in their
robot like that's what's happening right
now
um and I guess Amon just wanted to scare
Luke and then fly away but you know Luke
was terrified arax was terrified and
arak's reaction eventually uh was to
burn Vega like RX swoops up and and
shoots a gout of flame at Vega which I
guess is a way of saying like [ __ ] off
leave me alone
which you know terrible idea
terrible idea to attack Vega because
that's only going to piss Vega off but
that was you know Ina arax's fear and
Desperation that's what arax did and
Luke did not order that because we hear
Luke saying
um no like don't do that no arax serve
me but then arax burned Vega so neither
Luke nor amond wanted to escalate this
into violence and then vegar gets pissed
off
um and ignores aemon's orders and then
kills arax and Luke so this was very
much like the dragons doing the violence
but I mean the the kids like amond and
Luke really led the dragons there
through this whole Chase sequence like
they were so dumb to do this Chase in
the first place
um but yeah like you know when you give
a kid a giant massive weapon
um you know I mean they say don't play
with fire this is what happens when you
play with fire
but yeah again it is very different to
the books because in the books it seems
like it was deliberate
anyway thanks for the Super Chat who
says vegar is a level 100 Pokemon emond
doesn't have enough Gym badges luanita
says do you think there are some
hardcore conservative viewers that
support aegon even though he is horrible
and don't want Rainier to be ruler just
because she is a woman
um I don't know I there's there's a lot
of people who think a lot of different
things leonida I mean certainly one of
the themes of the story in the books and
the show is that a lot of people don't
want Rainier to be Queen because she's
female and like this whole monarchical
system is based around
um male inheritance
um so yeah that is a political angle
thanks for the Super Chat from biotic
who says
sneaking up on the characters how did
giant granny Vega sneak up on Luke I I
really like the way that they shot that
like Luke was like scared that vegar
might be chasing him and he's like
looking behind his shoulder and he's
like oh is Vega behind me and it's like
oh no Vega is above me and vegar like
swoops over from above and we see like
the Thunder lighting up the sky and we
see Vega it's like the opening shot of
Star Wars A New Hope in it
um it's like the big swooping spaceship
the great power over the smaller
Underdog I really like that shot
Jessa says so sad that Luke didn't even
want driftmark anymore because it would
mean everyone else would have to die now
he's the first casualty yeah that's a
good point that's a good irony that like
earlier on Luke was saying
um I don't want to be there because you
know I'll only take drift Mark when
everyone else is dead but nope it was
Luke who died before anyone else and I
really like you know the opening shot of
this episode was Luke on the painted
table
um touching the drift Mark symbol on the
painted table and saying that I should
not be the Lord of driftmark and so
again I think that reminds us that you
know it is the parents fault for putting
their kids in this political situation
that they are just not prepared for and
don't want I mean it parallels aegon
like aegon did aegon says a similar
thing in the previous episode where
aegon was saying I don't want to be king
I am not suited to be king and Luke here
is saying the same thing he says I
should not be the Lord of driftmark
because I'd get seasick like and the
Lord of driftmark is in charge of the
biggest Navy in the world like it makes
no sense and also there's the fact that
Luke is not really lane or valerion's
son so like it's such a shitty situation
to be in
and the death of Luke also raises
political questions about driftmark
because you know Luke was going to marry
uh Rayna Targaryen and so Luke and Rhino
were going to be the rulers of Riff Mark
or you know Luke was the ruler and uh
Rayna would be his lady but now you know
that marriage is dissolved so like who's
gonna get driftmark now like I suppose
that driftmark will now go to
um
Luke's younger son Joffrey valerion
Joffrey has a role in the books like
when uh they send Luke and uh Jason Luke
off to fly to their allies
um in the books Joffrey little little
Joffrey the youngest kid is like I want
to go too because Joffrey also has a
dragon and so Joffrey's like I want to
go and fly and help as well and Rainier
is like no no you're too young like
Jason Luke can go but Joffrey is staying
at home
um but you know Joffrey was really eager
to participate as well
I hope we get to see more of Joffrey
good kid thanks for the Super Chat from
Kyle who says what differences are there
between show amond and book aemond up
until this point
um well we talked about some of the
differences
um I I think mostly they're pretty
faithful like again like the show mostly
like
fleshes out the details but it mostly
stays faithful to like the overall
structure like the basic summary that's
in the books I mean it is a big change
that in the books it seems that aemond
deliberately killed Luke
um whereas in the show it seems to have
been Vega amond wasn't in control
um but otherwise I think they're pretty
similar I mean I mean one I mean one
difference is that like you know for the
previous episode uh they mentioned that
when they find aemond and and when they
tell aemond that like hey
um
king viserys is dead
um amon's reply is um let me get a quote
for you you'll enjoy this um aemon's
reply is is aegon king or must we kneel
and kiss the old [ __ ] cunny
yeah that is the regrettable words of
aemond Targaryen when he's saying are we
gonna make my brother aegon king or are
we gonna have to submit to rhaenyra
that's what he calls Rainier they call
Rainier a [ __ ] a lot uh in the books
um uh part of like you know people use
rhaenyra's sexuality to disparage her
like that you know since a lot of people
know
um that rhaenyra's children are the
bastards of Harwin strong and you know
now she's hooked up with Daemon and had
another couple of kids and you know she
was married to Lenor who a lot of people
knew was gay
um and people are prejudiced against
that and you know call Rainier a big old
[ __ ] and says that she shouldn't be in
charge because of that which is ironic
because aegon has lots of bastards and
aegon rapes people and yet not many
people disparage him for his sexuality
um so you know that's part of the theme
is like the misogyny of that
um being used against rhaen era
thanks for the Super Chat from blackfyre
who says rhaenyra preferred to refuse
help and birth a scaly corpse than be
yet another victim of the crown of
knives which took her mother and
sister-in-law yeah that that's a great
Point blackfyre like while rhaenyra is
in labor
um and she and she's angry and horrified
giving birth like no doubt what is going
through her mind is the memory of her
mother Emma who who died
um in the child bed had her baby cut out
of her body in that horrific C-section
that killed her
um and in the books
um her grandmother dayella Targaryen
died in childbirth
um and yeah Lena died in childbirth so
yeah no doubt that is what Rainier is
thinking about when she's like I don't
want this to be happening this should
not be happening and you know the
knowledge that it's premature and the
knowledge that the baby might not
survive
really horrific stuff
thanks for the Super Chat from Mr itani
muli who says granny Vega thought she
was back in Dawn yeah that's one of the
memes that I really enjoy is you know a
lot of people are making memes about how
Vega is is basically just like a
daughtery old woman who who is sort of
losing her Marbles and she thinks that
you know she just keeps thinking about
her her old writer vasenia and the wars
in Dawn and she's just like
are we are we going to sunspear to
barbecue some more donation and aemon's
like no no but it's it's the greens and
the blacks Vega it's a different thing
now and she's like okay I enjoy that
Meme
um and you know it also Bears
remembering that Veigar is um vegar has
caused so much destruction
like Vega as my I mean Vega you know
it's not really Vega's Choice how she is
used
sometimes I guess it is her choice in
this case but like you know Vega
participated in the wars of Conquest
um and after the wars of Conquest there
was this period called the dragon's
wrath where aegon's uh sister wife
rhaenys was killed in Dawn and so aegon
and vicenya went and just burned the
crap out of dawn repeatedly like there's
a line about like every Castle in Dawn
was was raised to a scorched desolation
three times over and like thousands of
people were killed killed by Vega and
valerion in Dawn
um and it's like after Vega has been
used for such destruction so many times
it's like well it's not surprising that
that Vega's first instinct is violence
you know like vegar is too old to to put
up with this [ __ ]
like very vegar is too old to be dealing
with with this rivalry between these
teenagers so you better believe if some
whippersnapper Dragon you know bursts
some flame in her face she's gonna Chomp
the [ __ ] like that's what Vega
does you know so it kind of makes
perfect sense
thanks for the Super Chat from Elm who
says do you foresee a glimpse of the
world Beyond the Wall in future seasons
I mean that they have like one of the
bigger changes in the show is that they
talked about this prophecy about the
targaryens needing to unite against the
White Walkers and that is not something
that is mentioned in in this part of the
books
so it would not be crazy for them to
explore that a little bit like I would
be shocked if we you know saw any white
walkers in this show I I that would
surprise me but I I don't suppose it's
impossible because I mean you know like
the white walkers are you know that they
do exist at this point in the story The
White Walkers are like dormant at this
point in the story it seems which might
be because of all the dragons in the
world it's all very mysterious like when
the white walkers are around and when
the dragons are around it is possible
that like
the drag the the white walkers are
dormant because there's lots of dragons
around at the moment like you know this
is the time of fire but then after the
dragons die out it becomes like a Time
Of Ice And there's sort of like meta
magic seasonal cycles of Ice and Fire I
mean that is pure speculation but that
is that might be something like what's
going on
um and you know Jace has been told to
fly to Winterfell and to talk to Craig
and Stark and so you know that would be
an opportunity to talk about some white
walkery stuff
um
so you know anything's possible
um if you're interested in some of the
you know white walkery secrets of the
North and the Starks you might not you
might like to watch the ultimate x video
called ancient Stark secrets that's a
fun video and that goes into ideas about
how the Starks might have intermarried
with the white walkers the Starks might
have white walker blood you know the
wall might have been built to facilitate
child sacrifice to the White Walkers
ancient agreements ancient pacts if
you're interested in any of those old
stark white walker Mysteries you might
like to watch that that video ancient
Stark Secrets
um thanks for the Super Chat from
Heather who says the more rainiaces
reveal the more rainies reveals herself
I agree with Allison that she would have
been an amazing Queen she is wise with a
perfect temperament thank you for the
live chats thank you heather
um yeah I mean rainey's thought
carefully about her decisions in this
episode like rainey's At first seemed as
though she would not commit to Rainier
or would not commit to Alison like I
think it is wise for her to not want to
get involved in this conflict because
she doesn't want more of her family to
die
um I don't know if rainy's decision
making was great in the previous episode
when rainey's like killed a whole bunch
of innocent common people like I I still
feel weird about that uh in the previous
episode when when rhaenys and melis like
burst up through the floor and a bunch
of common people got squashed it's
really hard to see like how many common
people squashed
how many common people died I mean it
looks like a lot like it looks like it
must be hundreds who died but like the
way that it was shot did not focus on
the common people so you know and then
in the inside the episode they were all
saying wow what a great heroic moment
for rhaenys and there was like no
acknowledgment of the people that she
killed
um which is weird because it clashes
with her like Mercy to the greens you
know and I'm not sure how much that is
deliberate on the part of the show
Runners like do the showrunners want us
to think wow rainey's is so cool and so
peaceful she was merciful or did the
showrunners want us to think wow kind of
messed up that she killed all those
common people but nice that she saved
the greens I guess I I'm holding out
hope that it will make sense in the long
run like I'm not gonna spoil anything
but
you know mazario warned us
the only Power is what the people let
you have you know so we are we are being
told that the people matter
um but yeah look I think that rhaenys
has shown some wisdom like apart from
the murdering the common people I think
that Randy's does show some wisdom
um throughout the season like she's she
she thinks before she acts and I think
that she has been burned before you know
like she's an older person she's seen
some [ __ ] she's seen people make
mistakes she has suffered loss and so
she doesn't want to LEAP into anything
without
um considering it first
um and I I do like rainis Point here
um when rainy says like caller says Hey
like let's not participate in the war
but then Rainey says no we have to
participate in the war because at this
point it's too late like maybe if we
made better decisions earlier we could
have avoided this war but at this point
like we are involved in this war
um there's no escaping it like that's my
interpretation of what rhaenys says
um so you know I think that makes sense
um and I like the role that rainey's
plays this episode in convincing call
list like we've got to participate here
and that obviously is a huge deal
because the valerions are so powerful
um
and the blacks really need them in order
to survive
Johnny in the live chat says rhaenys
doesn't give a duck
power is power
team diggers too much pride
yeah thanks to the donation from Kayla
who says what are your feelings on the
maybe new upcoming Jon Snow show uh yeah
does Game of Thrones season 8 need a
sequel
I don't know I don't know Georgia or
Martin the author has said that he's
excited about the Jon Snow show if
George thinks it's a good idea then
maybe it is a good idea I mean I thought
that this house of the dragon show might
be a bad idea but it turned out to be
good so maybe the Jon Snow show would be
good my question is like what is the Jon
Snow show about like we saw Jon Snow go
beyond the wall hanging out with some
wildlings like what's he gonna do like
is he gonna get involved in wildling
politics is he gonna fight some Finns is
he gonna be a diplomat with the
scargoshi like the stakes have gone down
like presumably John won't be involved
in southern politics
because they're not going to bring back
all the actors like Sansa and bran are
they
um I don't know what the Jon Snow show
would be about I would like it if it was
just like a really like low-key drama
with like just John in like a love
triangle with a couple of wildlings you
know just going hunting for food and
making snow castles like that you could
do some fun things like some chill
things low-key drama things but like
it's Game of Thrones they want bombast
they want sword fights and Dragons so
are they gonna bring back the white
walkers
oh it what what's that Star Wars rise of
Skywalker quote
somehow the night King returned is that
what they're gonna do in the Jon Snow
show I I it doesn't seem like a great
idea to me but I hope I will be proven
wrong
and I mean keep in mind that like
there's
it's not like like it's just in
development most shows in development
don't get made into actual shows it's
unlikely that all of these shows are
going to be made that are actually going
to make it to air so we'll see what
happens
thanks for the Super Chat from Caesar
who says what do you think about how
they changed Luke's death I think we've
already talked about it I I it is a bold
change to make it seem like an accident
um it raises questions about amon's
character I think it fits with the theme
of like historical inaccuracy like the
the book Fire and Blood is all about how
things are always more complicated than
the history books say and sometimes
rumor and bias gets in the way and I do
like the idea of aemond being like oh
[ __ ] like I I'm a kinslayer by accident
so I better pretend I killed Luke on
purpose and I've just got to embrace the
role of the villainous kin Slayer like I
think that's kind of a fun idea for
aemond
and you know it's sort of similar even
like Daemon you know plays with the idea
of his depraved reputation and like all
the questions about your rep your
reputation versus the reality are all
interesting questions it's you know I I
think it's cool and also like it does
sort of make perfect sense in terms of
like the dragon law like Daenerys has a
lot of trouble controlling her dragons
and you know these are children trying
to wield weapons of war and it's like
well of course of course there'd be
accidents I mean accidents happen in
real wars I mean like nuclear Armageddon
almost happened a couple of times during
the Cold War because like someone
someone someone you know some wires got
crossed and there was some confusion
about orders and like you know wasn't
there one time some like you know Soviet
nuclear submarine almost launched the
nukes but then they were like oh whoops
countermand that we'd spilled coffee on
the console it we didn't actually mean
to send those orders or whatever you
know accidents happen in Wars but I I
think that you could say that the the
this Showhouse of the Dragon has Maybe
it it has maybe done too much
it has maybe made this conflict too much
of an accident too much of a whoopsie
like there's a lot of weird like
accidents in the season like for example
Alice and misunderstands viserys's words
Alison in the show believes that viserys
wants aegon to be king
but he but she's wrong viserys was
actually talking about aegon's prophecy
and viserys actually wanted rhaenyra to
be king that that's a big change from
the books in the books there's no
mention of that in the books Alison just
wants her son aegon to be king
um and making it like a tragic
misunderstanding
leading to conflict you know I I I think
that takes away the power of the
character-driven decisions like I think
the story is more powerful when
characters make choices as opposed to
characters make accidental mistakes and
misunderstandings like you don't want
the story to all just be a series of
random occurrences you want the story to
be driven by character decisions
so I I think that you could argue that
house of the Dragon has has added too
many accidents
into the story but you know
uh your take may vary thanks for the
Super Chat from Jess who says amond
being an accidental kin Slayer reminds
me of Micah and Baylor yeah that's a
good comparison
um in the Hedge Knight which is one of
the Game of Thrones uh prequel stories
there's an incident where uh there's a
trial by combat where a bunch of of
knights and a couple of princes
participate in this big uh battle for
the life of Duncan the tall and it's a a
fun little dramatic fight that happens
where my car accidentally kills
um this other prince uh bailor
breakspeare and and it's really sad and
tragic because Baylor was the heir to
the throne and everyone loved Baylor and
Baylor was like a great guy so like my
car has to live for the rest of his life
going like oh [ __ ] like I accidentally
killed my family this is [ __ ] up
um and it's really sad and tragic and um
yeah aim on dissimilar
uh Sean asks about a alt shrift X Dune
live stream that may happen best dad
says will we see other Valyrian swords
in future Seasons uh yes there will be
other Valerian swords I mean we've got
like Blackfire The ancestral sword of
the Conqueror we've got dark sister the
sword of vicenya now carried by Daemon
um and yeah there are other swords
around there is a Hightower sword if I
remember Riley and killed I hope that
kildagar's Valyrian ax turns up that
would be cool as well uh but yeah good
idea to keep an eye on the Valyrian
swords and I like how they emphasize
like the political symbolic significance
of these swords
um thanks for the Super Chat from case
who says what is the status of driftmark
by the time Game of Thrones happens I
feel like it's never mentioned yeah it's
really interesting that that the
valerions are just kind of irrelevant by
the time of the main series like right
now the valerions are like probably the
second most powerful house in the realm
uh but in the main Game of Thrones
storyline the valerions swear to support
uh Stannis because you know Stannis is
on Dragonstone and the valerions
traditionally support Dragonstone and
then the crown lands and whatnot
um but yeah the valerians are just not
very important I think one of them dies
um it mentions that they're blonde like
so they have that like Valerian blonde
hair in the books but yeah they're just
not very important anymore which which
is a little bit like you know like with
hot D it's like oh there's all these
dragons around and then you watch later
on the Game of Thrones show there's no
dragons and you're like huh something
happened to all the dragons and we think
the same thing about uh house valerion
house valarion is really powerful in
House of the Dragon but in Game of
Thrones they're irrelevant so it's like
huh what happened to the valerians
that's something that we're going to
find out about
what causes the downfall of the
valerians
and and you know also like the power of
house valerion is a recent development
like keep in mind that it was
specifically corliss's voyages that made
house for Larry on super powerful in
recent times he it was him who made the
valerians super rich and built their
Newcastle
um so you know it's it's not like the
valerians have always been this powerful
I I can pull up some more valerion
information if we're interested
um yeah so it's Lord Montford
valerion who supports Stannis on
Dragonstone in book two
and they talk about montford's arrogance
having the blood of valyria and his
house had provided Brides for Targaryen
princes including you know a reference
to Elena there in book two of Game of
Thrones
um and some of the valerion ships burn
at the Battle of the Blackwater remember
like when Tyrion blew up the bay with
the Wildfire there were some Valerian
valerions burning in there
um
uh Lord Montford died in the Battle of
the Blackwater and the new Lord valerion
was Lord monterus valerion uh in book
three a six-year-old becomes the new
leader of house valerion so that's
probably another reason why they're not
very significant in the main series and
oh and yeah we do have orain Waters who
is a valerion bastard who is
um gets invited to cersei's small
Council Cersei makes oreign her Admiral
and Cersei builds orain a bunch of very
expensive ships and then orain leaves
and takes the ships or rainwater's
steals the very expensive Royal Fleet
and and becomes a pirate king
um so not a great decision by Cersei
though uh so yeah there's several
reasons why the valerians are less
powerful
thanks for the Super Chat from Factory
who says Nick Covey and Michelle's watch
party appreciate your content thanks for
your expertise thank you factory glad
you're enjoying the Gaia says how did
Daemon know about Luke's fate wouldn't
he and arax's bodies just be lost in the
narrow sea yeah that's a good question I
mean I think that the people of Storm's
end would have seen that there was a
fight there was Fire in the Sky
um but yeah I mean I guess yeah they
wouldn't have known for sure until like
I guess maybe at this point amont has
already returned to King's Landing and
already told the greens that Luke is
dead but like yeah I mean maybe maybe
the greens would want to keep it quiet
that Luke died for as long as possible
to try and do some damage control like
just like the greens tried to keep it
quiet that King viserys was dead last
episode maybe they also would try to not
spread it around that Prince Luke was
murdered by Prince amond
um so yeah that's a reasonable question
like like maybe it shouldn't you know
but I mean we also don't know how much
time has passed until that final scene
with Rainier like me for all we know it
could be days or weeks since since the
death until Rainier finds out so you
know she found out somehow
thank you Alchemist thank you Joshua
mixed opinions about the Jon Snow show
uh no spoilers platypus thank you for
the Super Chat from Smith who says as a
new father that birth was hard to watch
took me back to the fear and anxiety I
had before the birth yeah I thought it
was well done
double duck says why do the dragons kill
other dragons so easily without thought
do they share the same feelings and
intentions as their Rider
yeah well I mean Vega Vega's old she's
had enough of everybody's [ __ ]
um she's grumpy like the books say that
Veigar is is sleepy and and grumpy and
is just a crotchety old grandma a
crotchety old murder Grandma
um and you know dragons are inherently
destructive like dragons are fire made
flesh dragons don't settle their
disputes with with diplomacy and I
suppose they're not particularly
sociable creatures either like it's it
says in the books that they tend to make
their layers alone in in mountains and
caves and and they sort of spend a lot
of time just just chilling alone in
their caves is what it is what it sounds
like so you know dragons are destructive
angry aggressive creatures I mean
something to keep in mind is that
dragons are possibly not natural like it
is hinted in the books that dragons were
created by ancient Valyrian blood magic
from wyverns or wivens like there are
these creatures your creatures called
weavens who come from the jungles of
sothorios and they are like dragons but
they don't breathe fire
and it's hinted that the ancient
Valyrian blood Mages took wivens and did
some kind of dark blood magic to imbue
them with the power of fire and also to
like create some kind of
hybridization with humans
um there's all sorts of
um spooky horrifying stuff going on with
like Valyrian blood magic
um and it sounds as though like the
targaryens as a people may have been
created by Blood Magic by like
hybridizing them with dragons and that
is how targaryens have this like magical
connection to dragons
this these
um images by the way were created with
um an AI image generation program this
is night Cafe
um stable diffusion
was used to make a bunch of these
scary images of Valyrian blood magic
which I think are pretty cool anyway
um yeah so like dragons are like they're
not like natural creatures they are like
magic creations and this and the books
are always talking about how magic is
like inherently dangerous and
destructive and uncontrollable
so I think it makes perfect sense that
dragons are not only destructive of
their enemies dragons are like
self-destructive
um that's what they are that's what
they're for they are weapons and just as
you know the dragons
led to the destruction of valyria
according to viserys in episode one it
makes sense that they sort of destroy
each other and you know lead to the
downfall of um
well we'll see thanks for the Super Chat
from math debater club who says I think
a consistent theme of the show is the
disregard of Royals towards common folk
almost every time a moral decision is
made there is literally zero
consideration for anyone besides Nobles
yeah I mean Allison says several times
that she wants to look after the realm
she wants like she says repeatedly like
we need to make peace we need to do
what's best for the realm and then you
know she proceeds to Crown a monstrous
rapist as king so she's not doing a
great job of it but Alison at least is
paying lip service to the idea of
looking after the common people
um but yeah like there is not enough
consideration of the comments going on
here and that's what mazaria said last
episode she said like we got to care
about the people
um so yeah that is a theme that they are
exploring and will continue to explore
and that's very much part of Game of
Thrones as well I mean especially the
books um The Game of Thrones show had
less emphasis on the common people and
The Peasants but in the books there is
like a lot of time like you know Brienne
in the riverlands and Aya in the
riverlands and like there's a huge focus
on how much it sucks for everybody who
isn't a lord or a lady or a king or a
queen because of the decisions of the
high Lords so that that is something
that they should Explore More as the
series goes on
vatio says I understand the show has
communicated to us that aegon has a
messed up moral compass is there
anything you can say about this and
whether there is redemption
yeah I mean I'm interested like in the
idea of honor and and chivalry like I
think Kristen Cole especially shows us
this idea of you know Kristen murders
people but he thinks that's okay because
it's honorable and it's chivalrous and
he's defending the honor of Allison and
defending himself and you know that
there's like a moral system in place in
this world
where you know
um following certain rules around like
the hierarchy and around sexuality are
considered more important than you know
like violence is okay in this system
um
whereas like having sex with the wrong
person is not and so you know George is
exploring that like particular like
medieval value system
um
I mean aegon I think is just a bit of a
[ __ ] I mean aegon is a terrible person
who doesn't care about other people's
feelings and so he he rapes people and
he has children in a he I mean he lets
his child be a slave in a child fighting
pit like I think aegon's just being a
like I I don't think we can say that
aegon is like the product of his Society
I think aegon is is an exceptionally
um unpleasant person
um and you know like I do think that I I
do like how they explore aegon's
feelings of rejection from his parents
he feels ignored by viserys and by
Allison he feels used by them
um and so you know it makes a kind of
sense that aegon seeks after validation
in other places
um you know doesn't justify his actions
but it makes it more understandable and
you know as we've said in videos that's
very similar to Tyrion George Martin is
always very interested in exploring like
Daddy Issues like a lot of characters in
A Song of Ice and Fire feel rejected by
their parents and that drives a lot of
their
negative emotions so
that's a big part of what's going on and
I mean you know there's also like just
the there's also just seeing how like
political pressures affect people's
decisions like I mean a big part of it
is just about how this goddamn monarchy
is just such a terrible idea like like
the idea that there is one person who
has ultimate power over this entire
continent and the only way to make a
change of government is murder and or
War right like there's no Democratic
option to vote out a king because
they're terrible no like you've got to
start a war and a lot of people have got
to die and so you know the stakes are so
high that
um making these sort of brutal decisions
are sometimes necessary I mean Otto is a
[ __ ] But Otto is is is right uh to
some extent that like I mean you know
Otto's been arguing for a while that the
reason why we must wage war against
rhaenyra is that no one will accept
Rainier as a ruler and if Rainier takes
the throne there will be a war so it's
better that we kill rhaenyra
to prevent a larger world that will kill
more people and that is like a you know
that's a really dark argument but he
might be right you know like I mean it's
like Taiwan says it is better to kill a
few people at the Red Wedding than to
start a war that will kill thousands
more
um and you know tywin's a horrible
villain but but there may be some truth
in some of the things that he says I
mean Tywin was wrong in that instance
but you know I mean there's this moment
in the books when Davos is talking to
Stannis and Stannis is saying you know
we should sacrifice one boy we're gonna
burn edric storm so that I can get my
crown like it is it is worth it to
sacrifice one child in order to save
thousands of lives and prevent a war
as a you know it's similar to in the
show when Stannis Burns Shireen like
making the sacrifice of one child to
save a kingdom
and there's a line in the books where
Stannis says like what is the life of
one child against a kingdom and Davos
says everything
like yes like you can make these
Machiavellian
decisions about like sacrifice for the
greater good but that we lose some of
our Humanity when we make those choices
even if they are rational
it is it is not right and it's not human
to let children die to sacrifice kids
and that's what you know Otto wants to
do Otto wants to murder rhaenyra and
Daemon and their children probably so
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
complicated moral stuff going on that
that intersects with the the social and
cultural realities in Westeros and with
the emotional psychological issues of
these characters I I think ultimately
it's just a really bad idea to give a
person a sword and say your life is more
important than others I mean it's also
just an indictment on the hierarchy in
this world the feudal hierarchy where
some people are better than others and
you know that's part of why rainy's
Rampages through those common people in
the previous episode like rhaenys thinks
really hard about like hmm should I kill
Alison and aegon who you know they are
my family maybe I should show them Mercy
meanwhile her dragon is like tail
swiping peasants just like yeeting them
into the wall and it's like she doesn't
give them much consideration and that's
because of this you know feudal
hierarchy some people are more important
than others and their books are very
focused on exploring how [ __ ] up that
is
thanks uh where's the poll yeah all
right good good point we'll do a poll
all right
um there's a poll in the live stream
live chat who do you support
Alison and the greens or Rainier and the
blacks okay
the poll is now live
in the live stream
I feel like I would um I feel like I
would
I don't want to bias the pole in any
direction but I feel like you know as
any pollster will say the wording of a
poll is important
um and we could say do you do you
support aegon and the greens
or we could say do you support Alison
and the greens and I feel like less
people are going to vote for aegon than
for Alison but aegon is is you know he's
the he's the king he's the claimant to
the throne so I suppose it should say
aegon not Alison but um
you know it's worth remembering who
we're fighting for
uh so far uh the votes are in we've got
2 000 votes in and it says 89 of you
support Rainier which is very similar to
the previous polls I don't remember the
exact numbers but I think it was similar
89 percent
um so overwhelmingly we support Rainier
and you know I I'm I'm not surprised
because rhaenyra is who viserys wanted
to inherit the throne and aegon is a
pretty horrible person and obviously not
suited to be king
um
you know Kristen's a [ __ ] oh there's
a odd was a [ __ ] Laris is a [ __ ]
and they're all on the greens side
Daemon is also a pretty violent
unpleasant person but he uh is Doctor
Who and he's hot so I think a lot of
people like him anyway so yeah
overwhelming support for the blacks 3
000 votes in and 89 like the blacks
thanks for the Super Chat from Crimson
who says pretty sure it was just rainys
needing to escape yeah so I mean there
is ambiguity about
rainy says Escape in the previous
episode like you know maybe bursting up
through the floor was the only way that
rhaenys could have possibly escaped and
therefore rhaenys was justified
um I guess you could make that argument
I mean if you want to you know if we
want to think about I mean rainey's
could have just stayed
underground in the dragon pit until the
common people left maybe and you know I
mean rhaenys did know that there were
thousands of people above her in the
dragon pit like she was standing in the
audience
um she was standing right next to those
people before she burst up and killed
some of them
um I feel like rainey's could have you
know tried to avoid killing those people
it also is weird like
well isn't there a ramp like previously
when we've seen the dragon pit uh there
is there's this ramp that the dragons
come up from see over here
um
but it looks like the greens like
cover over those ramps they must put
some like boards I suppose over the ramp
and so the Beast bursts up from below
the boards so like I I guess that ramp I
mean maybe that ramp is the only exit
from the dragon pit and maybe rainey's
had to burst through one way or another
um
but yeah I feel like she could have
tried to avoid killing those people uh
Andre asks about the dragon that Daemon
went to see that is Verma Thor the
bronze Fury the dragon of uh jiharis the
king before viserys it is a powerful old
dragon that the books say that dragons
just like keep on growing as they grow
older like dragons never stop growing
they just grow and grow and grow until
they die
um
and that's you know why Veigar is so
monstrously huge uh and so generally the
older dragons are more powerful I mean
the older dragons are usually slower
um but they're also usually tougher
because the books say that dragon scales
get stronger and dragon scales like fuse
together as the dragon gets older so
they become almost impervious to arrows
and swords and fire and like one of the
only ways to for a human to kill a big
old dragon is with like a scorpion bolt
to the eye if you're like really really
lucky however dragons can kill dragons
um but the bigger ones have an advantage
Taylor says my head Cannon is not that
vegar and arax disobeyed amond and Luke
but rather they were responding to the
subconscious feelings of those two boys
who were not fully in control of their
emotions yeah I I like that
interpretation because you know these
boys are teenagers who are learning how
to deal with their feelings there's a
lot of testosterone going on a lot of
fear
um and despite aemon's words you know
and despite Luke's words saying like
telling the dragons not to fight I think
they might feel a desire to fight anyway
um and the dragons might sense that
because yeah like there are hints in the
books that the dragons can sense the
feelings of their Riders and they may be
you know responding to the feelings of
the writers as much or more than they
are listening to the commands because if
we use our brain like there's no way the
dragons can hear the words of these kids
during the buffeting storm like
especially with Vega like Vega's hearing
probably isn't so good at this point
she's probably got hearing aids
um and vegar's ears are like are like 50
meters away from aemon's mouth like
there's no way that they can actually
hear the commands it's got to be a
psychic thing I mean look here we are
speculating on this on the science of
Dragons It's Magic it doesn't matter but
but yes like I agree with you Taylor
that it may be like a psychic thing and
and and and that connects to what we
were saying about like these are kids
these are teenagers you should not give
teenagers control of giant dragons
thank you for the Super Chat from
Jeffrey who says would it not have been
a better idea to send rhaenys who is the
daughter of a Baratheon to deliver the
message to Storm's end yeah that's a
great idea I think that definitely would
have been smarter because boros might be
a bit of a dick but he at least
um he has more of a connection to
rhaenys than he does too Luke valerion
um I think that boros does say though uh
at some point in this chapter that like
oh rainy Saint [ __ ] I don't remember the
exact wording but I think boros says in
this chapter that like oh yeah like we
have a you know I have that cousin but
but whatever I'm not I don't really care
about rainis that much maybe I'm
misremembering but I I think
I think Borough says something like that
oh yeah he said all right quote I
princess rhaenys is kin to me and mine
some great aunt I never knew was married
to her father but the both of them are
dead and rhaenyra she's not raining is
she
he had nothing against women Lord boros
went on to say he loved his girls her
daughter is a precious thing but a son
ah Storm's end would pass to his son not
to his sisters so so yeah in the books
boros does talk about rhaenys and he's
like ah she's like you know a cousin
whatever like I'm not that interested so
yeah maybe even sending rainey's might
not have helped
thanks for the Super Chat from Daniel
who says I really appreciate how the
dragons have real Personalities in Game
of Thrones in Game of Thrones they felt
like magic jets that could Intuit
Direction but here they seem like
nuclear dogs I love that description
Daniel nuclear dogs I agree they have
all of the they have all of the
personality and loyalty and danger and
and rapidity of of a dog lots of
different colors and shapes and sizes uh
but they also happen to have
thermonuclear Firepower yeah I like that
description and yeah like like in Game
of Thrones it sucked because viserion
and rhaegal and dragon were all almost
identical shades of murky Brown most of
the time uh whereas in Hot D the dragons
are all different colors as they are
described in the books different colors
and they have different like shapes and
and sizes and curraxis is a freaky
noodle neck and um and it's wonderful
and Vega has got a big
flippity gouty neck jangling around
which is also really fun I loved the
sounds that Rainier is Dragon Cyrax made
in this episode lots of squawky sounds
that the dragons sound a bit like birds
and and I mean you know like birds are
dinosaurs technically aren't they or
dinosaurs are birds dinosaurs
technically they say non-avian dinosaurs
now I don't know but in in the real
world that you know there's a connection
between birds and and reptiles and
dinosaurs and I and I like how the sort
of squawking Dragon sounds sort of evoke
that bird-like nature so yeah they're
like birds they're dogs
uh they're wonderful the dragons are
much better in hot day than they were in
Game of Thrones and we're going to see a
whole lot more of them later on yeah
caraxi's the spicy noodle the danger
noodle danger Sky dog lots of good
descriptions in the live chat
thanks for the Super Chat from Hunter
who says uh I think this set up a nice
potential Revenge fight with Jace and
amont even though I think only Daemon or
Eric could beat him in combat
yeah it does seem like aemond is one of
I I mean amond has Vega the most
powerful weapon of war in the world but
even without vegar uh amond appears to
be a powerful Warrior and the books say
that Kristen trained Eamonn to be a
powerful Warrior so yeah I mean Daemon
is definitely one of the most powerful
warriors so maybe maybe Daemon could
defeat aemond I mean I mean Daemon has a
lot of experience of actual war from his
years on the stepstones whereas aemond
has no experience of actual War he only
has training so and you know like Daemon
is older and bigger aymond is you know
maybe not fully grown so yeah I reckon
Daemon would have a good chance of
defeating aemond in combat but we'll
just have to see won't we
Shane says who do you think Verma Thor's
Rider will be uh well I think one
possibility is Raina Targaryen like that
they they there was a shot of rayna's
face when
um when they talked about the wild
dragons on Dragonstone who might be
claimed
um because you know we learned in pentos
that Reina feels left out that you know
her twin sister Baylor has a dragon
called Moon Dancer a young dragon uh
whereas raina's dragon egg never hatched
and so Rainer is hopeful that she might
be able to claim a dragon at some point
so yeah in theory Rayna could claim
Verma Thor or Silverwing or maybe maybe
sea smoke lots lots of options and there
are those wild dragons as well so yeah
maybe Rainer will will do it in in the
books they actually mentioned that Rayna
uh rayna's dragon egg did hatch in the
books but it was like a deformed
weakling Dragon hatchling that that soon
died
um so
so slight difference in the books
thanks for the Super Chat from well and
yeah and to talk a little more about the
dragon claiming thing
um you need Targaryen blood to claim a
dragon or at least Valyrian blood
um and so the reason why you know Baylor
and Rayna uh have Targaryen blood from
Daemon and Jace Luke and Joff have
Targaryen blood from rhaenyra
um so you know that they can't just
strap Eric Cargill to the bronze Fury
and expect it to work
um but you know since they have all
these dragons they have more dragons
than Riders uh we're gonna have to
figure out how to use those dragons
aren't we so that might be a plot Point
later on
thanks for the Super Chat from Jess who
says imagine if Vega was still around
during the time of dayron oh vicenia is
that a bunch of dornish snacks in the
city yeah because they're on the second
married a dornish woman and uh
facilitated the the uniting of the
Kingdom
um and vegar is Vega is probably a bit
racist If we're honest
but vegar is probably a racist old
grandma because uh because Vega oh [ __ ]
because Vega participated in uh the
attacks on Dawn by aegon and vasenya so
I I mean that's that's a thing in the
books is that you know a lot of people
uh are prejudiced against dornish people
because of the years of war and so when
day Ron intermarried with the dornish
some people uh were prejudiced against
him and his wife because of that so that
that's a whole that's a whole thing
Patrick says the dragon also saw the
passing of all the dragons she knew yeah
I mean there could be a generational gap
between Vega and the other dragons like
you know we don't know how much dragons
you know how intelligent dragons are how
much memory they have but yeah I mean
Vega probably misses her
egg siblings you know valerion and
maraxis like vegar is the last of her
Generation
Um and she might not she might not be
Pals with this new younger generation of
um
this new younger generation of dragons
so maybe that's another Gap
that's Vision I'm happy to find the
YouTube channel big shout out from
Norway thanks Vision Majid says
following the tradition of a shocking
episode 9. I feel like this episode
should have been the 9th and the 10th
would have been the reaction or
consequence
yeah I I guess you know traditionally
the ninth is like a big battle episode
or whatever in Game of Thrones
um but I guess yeah like I mean Luke's
death in this episode is more shocking
than anything happened in the previous
episode episode nine
I I mean I they don't need to fit that
pattern every time like I I think that
part of why they added like rainey's
bursting up on melis at the dragon pit
to episode nine which isn't in the books
I think they did that partly because
they felt like they needed a big
climactic violent moment
um in episode nine I I would have been
just as happy if they didn't have it I
thought aegon's coronation was great as
as like a climax for that episode I
don't know if they needed to add the
rhaenys thing
um
so yeah I don't know thanks Natalie who
says I think Luke's death was showing us
that viserys was right when he said that
targaryens don't really control their
dragons yeah I mean we've already
discussed that I think that
um that definitely is foreshadowing from
viserys there they're laying the
groundwork for this issue and it's good
that they also had like they also had
the dragon lessons
scenes
um which was also like you know like one
of the Dragon Keepers was was telling
Jace like you've got to control your
dragon you've got to do do a better job
of controlling your dragon so that that
has been an issue in Hot D for a while
and and now it's paying off and it ties
into that whole like you know playing
with fire playing with power destruction
magic like it's all about the dangers of
ambition the dangers of dreams like like
they they talk about Dragon dreams
because dragons are connected to dreams
of Freedom dreams of power dreams of you
know ego and desire that's what dragons
are so all of these stories are about
the um dangers of those things
uh yeah we discussed uh Maris negging
amond into attacking Luke we discussed
rhaenys
race says wild to see the children
experience the same conflict inertia
between them and the dragons as the
adults witnessed their children in
episode 8. that is a good point race I
agree
um because the whole thing in episode 8
um was that rhaenyra and Alison were
trying to make peace but their children
amond and Jace and Luke and aegon did
not get the memo um Alison and rhaenyra
you know they're old they're mature they
are singing viserys die before their
eyes and so they are wise enough to say
okay we've got to stop this conflict but
amond and aegon and Jason Luke the
teenagers full of testosterone and and
what was that rhaenys line uh full of
the the steel in their fists and Seed in
their loins whatever it was that rainy
said
um the kids continued the fight even
when the adults tried to stop it
conflict inertia indeed
um and we have a really similar similar
thing in this episode
where Luke and amond are trying to stop
this conflict or at least you know that
they're trying not to kill each other
they're trying to like pull back at this
point but then the dragons just continue
they carry the inertia of the conflict
and the dragons don't obey so
yeah I think that's a great point the
dragons the the conflict is passed on
and passed on and passed on generation
after generation and that even gets
passed down to the Dragons It's like a
conflict has a life of its own like hate
has a life of its own
um and even when the individuals try to
stop it the the force and the feeling
itself continues
um that there is this sense of like
inevitable tragic fate being against
them
um and everyone just being carried along
in this tide this wave of violence that
is sweeping them all up and uh it's
gonna lead to bad times
thanks for the Super Chat from Eric who
says what if lane or valerion comes back
pretending to be a Targaryen bastard fun
fun ideas interesting ideas I mean again
like Lena surviving is not in the books
um but you know there are potential
things they could do with the character
um what are some other things that I
wanted to say
um
serving the kingdom oh yeah I thought it
was interesting that like when rhaenyra
sent Jace and Luke out to visit the
other houses she made this comment about
like she made this weird comment about
uh
the targaryens are closer to Gods than
to men she tells her children which is a
weird thing to tell your child don't
tell your child that your child is a God
but she says we are closer to Gods than
men the Iron Throne puts us a touch
closer but if we are to serve the Seven
Kingdoms we must answer to their gods
and so then rhaenyra makes Jace and Luke
swear on the seven-pointed star which is
the holy book of the faith of the seven
so Rainier is saying like we don't
believe in the seven really uh but we're
going to pretend that we care about the
faith of the seven because most of
Westeros follows the faith of the seven
and if we want to rule them we need to
follow their religion and that's
something that aegon the Conqueror uh
did early on in his Conquest like the
targaryens and the valyrians
historically have not been very
interested in religion but they pretend
to be for political reasons
so I thought that was an interesting
thing for them to highlight and you know
you know that that also contrasts with
like the high towers and the greens have
a very enthusiastic Embrace of the faith
of the seven which is a which is a bit
more sincere I think although of course
ironically like Alison is wearing the
star of the faith of the seven and
Allison is talking about religion
um at the same time that she's you know
getting Laris to masturbate off her fate
and Kristen is murdering people and I
don't think the seven-pointed star has
any verses about
um foot masturbation so yeah religion
playing a role is important politically
um
they mentioned the dragon Keepers could
join the conflict like Daemon mentioned
that like you know we've got to like
work with what we've got militarily so
Daemon says that uh we you know we
should put some soldiers around the
perimeter of Dragonstone so that we look
like we have more soldiers than we
actually do and yeah he mentions that
the dragon keepers are good Fighters uh
because the dragon Keepers in the books
are described as like this
um a bunch of gods with like fancy
ornate dragon armor and the dragon
Keepers do seem to be like badass cool
fighters in the books so they may be
relevant which is cool I'm I'm happy
with what they've done with the dragon
keepers
um
I liked when Rainier first found out
um that aegon has been crowned as king
uh Rainier's reaction was uh him like
they crowned him it reminds me like you
know being arrested development when
they're like huh
she her him really aegon that
[ __ ]
if they made him King why
um and yeah we talked about how rhaenyra
in the books well during labor her labor
went for three days and she was like
crying curses against Allison Rainier is
much more aggressive much less peaceful
in the books uh her stillborn baby was
named visenya
um
we mentioned Lord celtega I thought it
was an interesting scene where Daemon
went and took these two kingsguard and
like threatened them with his Dragon
karaxis he like tells Jace I will show
you the meaning of loyalty and he like
threatens those King's Guard
um I thought that was an odd thing to do
but I mean the kingsguard are of um
questionable loyalty at this point I
suppose because like Eric left the
greens and Harold left the greens and
um it's not entirely clear whose side
the King's Guard is on like the King's
Guard is not normally split like this
but but that's the situation here and so
Daemon like intimidates the King's Guard
and threatens to make them die painfully
which is like all right Daemon like he's
obviously expressing his grief and his
how upset he is by you know threatening
violence as Daemon does
um but you know it sort of emphasizes
the question of like who are the kings
God loyal to
um we talked about yeah I thought it was
funny that like Otto when he's offering
the peace terms he's like ah aegon in
his wisdom has decided to offer you
peace when you know aegon
aegon's wisdom has nothing to do with it
it was Alison who wants to offer Pace I
almost wonder if Otto
I feel like Otto could have done a
better job of convincing rhaenyra to
make peace you know and and I feel like
Otto not being there would have been the
first decision like the the a good way
to make Rainier agree would have been
you know sending Alison to someone
instead of Otto but you know I guess
Auto does sincerely want rhaenyra to
submit you know even if he hopes to
murder marinara at some point but yeah I
feel like he could have done a better
job with that peace offer
um
I thought yeah I thought it was
interesting like that Otto said that
viserys like viserys and rhaenyra were
the last people to see it that aegon is
air as soon as aegon was born aegon was
Heir Otto says like Otto says the
Rainier was kidding herself if she
thought she was air and like the the son
the eldest son is always the uh
um and the fact that Otto says you you
and viserys were the last people to see
it like Otto is admitting there that he
was going against viserys's wishes by
plotting to support aegon like
Otto is like low-key almost admitting to
treason by saying that I was supporting
aegon even when viserys didn't realize
it you know
um Otto's being very bold with his words
there
uh in the books
rhaenyra Unchained or while like Orwell
is the grand maester uh and in the books
rhaenyra says oh well you all know
bloody Grand maester you're supporting
the illegitimate greens and the
illegitimate aegon so rhaenyra actually
tears off or while's uh maester chain in
the books and appoints her own Grand
maester in the books it's a shame that
they cut that that was fun in the books
I thought it was also very funny that uh
rhaenyra told Luke I expect you'll
receive a very warm welcome at Storm's
end
uh and when you know Luke was killed by
the dragon Veigar I suppose he
experienced a very warm welcome indeed
thanks for the Super Chat from Lewis who
says the premiere of the show had the
death of two targaryens and the finale
ended with the death of two targaryens
it's like poetry it rhymes yeah Emma and
Balon died in the in the premiere
episode and now the stillborn vicenia
and Luke died so yeah two deaths and I
think that that is most relevant to
rhaenyra I think because it sort of
mirrors how in episode one viserys lost
his wife Emma and lost his baby Balon
and that sort of defined his Reign from
then on and I think the fact that
rhaenyra has lost her child Luke and
lost her stillborn vesenia I think that
is going to Define her Reign so yeah I
think that is a
um parallel in a lot of ways
rabbit shoes says I like it's I like
that it's actually the dragons that kick
off the conflict aemond is responsible
but yeah yeah that yeah I mean it
connects to what viserys was saying
about like dragons destroyed valyria
like it's it's toying with power itself
that leads to the conflict Abby says
storms and Aesthetics was a glimpse of
what Westeros will was before the
conquest which the lore alone is
fascinating yeah that's a good point
because like a lot of these big castles
around Westeros are absurdly huge like
they're all these monuments like there's
the Hightower there's the wall there's
storms end there's Winterfell there's
moat Kalin the ruins of moat Kalin
there's all these like enormous castles
around which seem much bigger and much
more advanced than anything that is
built now so it seems like Westeros has
gone backwards technologically like like
they used to be more powerful stuff
around there was like some Golden Age
The Age of Heroes that has now declined
it may be that those structures were
built with the aid of magic to some
extent like Brandon the Builder the
legendary brand the Builder may have
been involved there are magical Wards in
Storm's end so yeah I mean maybe the
long night The Apocalypse of the long
night may have been what caused that
backward slide in technology maybe it's
a post-apocalyptic world that we're
living in Westeros so and you know like
those monuments of past Glory are a
reminder of the dangers of downfall you
know like
it's possible that we all can be reduced
from our former glory it's a warning not
to be too arrogant but I'm not sure if
the targaryens are listening
and some of what I just said was more
speculation than actual law but that's
the sense that I get from it anyway uh
Sasha says I thought Storm's end looks
lame a tall tower doesn't bode well in
stormy seas yeah well I'm not sure about
the structural Integrity
um of that Tower but I like the
symbolism of like it's described in the
books as like a fist being directed at
the sky like a [ __ ] you to the gods
um
I would have liked to have seen a bit
more of the like the Big Stone drum at
the base of it yeah I mean it does look
more like a big ass Tower
here in hot day whereas in the books
it's more of like a castle that has a
tower as part of it
I mean and the walls are like it's it's
meant to emphasize the walls in the book
and we don't see a whole lot of the
walls and you know it does look kind of
precarious the way that it's like
perched on this rock out thrust into the
sea so yeah it's not exactly how it's
described in the books but I still think
it looks cool
cash says I love the parallel between
the standoffs in Dragonstone between
Otto and Daemon in episode 2 and episode
10. yeah it was it was quite a similar
series of events that happened here
compared to when Daemon
um
took over Dragonstone just this time
Rainier is on daemon's side instead of
Otto's side I guess things have changed
huh I mean Daemon I mean it's funny that
all these years later daemon's reaction
is exactly the same which is Daemon just
wants to [ __ ] kill Otto and Daemon
draws his sword
um so it doesn't seem like Daemon has
changed very much but rhaenyra has
changed very much indeed
thanks for the Super Chat from Charles
tuning in every week love the streams
we'd love to know who your favorite
character was this season I mean I think
viserys is a great performance by Patty
considine there's just a lot of layers
to viserys
um I really enjoyed him
um you know Kristen I think is
interesting I think Alison is really
interesting
um she's managed to be like really
sympathetic and also horrible at the
same time
um I think larys steals every scene that
he's in I think that laras is it
perfectly captures the club foot uh as
described in the books he's he's so
mysterious and and nasty and intriguing
all at once and Matt Smith is enormously
charismatic as Damon like like you know
I was uh skeptical about Matt Smith
um being Daemon at first but I I think
he totally owns it I think he totally
captures Daemon so um so yeah a lot of
good performances
Seeker says uh
well Seeker mentions the cannibal yeah
we won't spoil anything but but there is
a wild Dragon called the cannibal who is
uh pretty cool pretty fun might see him
later
Hector says it would be cool if there
was a confrontation between an ice
dragon and a normal one yeah I mean we
don't know if ice dragons exist really
like the law mentions that there are
these
um ice dragon fellas
um who like breathe ice but it's
possible that those are just like a
legend like barely anyone has like seen
a nice dragon it might be more of like a
metaphor for like the cold winds around
the Frozen Seas of the North or whatever
but uh yeah they're cool it's a nice
little bit of World building I wouldn't
expect to see a nice dragon like turn up
anytime soon I mean George did also
write like a children's book called the
ice dragon and I think I haven't read it
but I think there's some
some people have some idea about like
the ice dragon melts and then the melted
Dragon forms the pool of water in the
Winterfell godswood I think that's an
idea that people like
um so that's fun but uh yeah look maybe
maybe we'll we'll find out some more
when um
when Jace flies his Dragon up to
Winterfell it's always interesting when
a dragon is in the north doesn't happen
too often always interesting when ice
and fire combines
Zeva Panda says I love how Otto tells
rhaenyra exactly what houses have not
pledged their allegiance to aegon yeah
what was it like the tyrells uh and the
Lannisters and the tullys did he mention
the tullies the tallies I think are
disputed
but yeah I mean I guess everyone wants
to claim what power they have uh ring
says yeah we kind of talked about that
wealthwolf says
is alt shift x a legitimized bastard of
alt shift X or is it more of a car Stark
situation I think it's more of a skagos
situation
I'll shift X is the cannibal Island uh
trash says Otto started all of this if
he hadn't pushed Alison none of this
tragedy would have happened I mean yes
and it's all viserys's fault because
viserys chose to marry Alison and chose
to have children with Alison and that if
that didn't happen then the conflict
wouldn't have happened and the reason
why viserys married Alison is because he
was horny for this teenager
um if he didn't do that selfish uh
morally questionable marriage then there
never would have been this issue and you
know also viserys
um failed to adequately
you know make it real clear and
indisputable that Rainier was his Heir I
mean really he should have considered
marrying aegon to rhaenyra I mean yes
there's a huge age Gap and it would have
been gross and weird but like if aegon
was married to Rainier and none of this
would be happening either you know like
there's just a lot of different
choices the viserys could have made to
prevent this conflict and he took none
of them
and yes he made his heroic walk uh in
the end but it was too little too late
so you know you can blame Otto you can
blame viserys you can blame Allison you
can blame rain era you can blame a lot
of people for this conflict and I think
the show very deliberately makes it
clear that you know that there's no one
answer there's no one villain there's a
lot of very complicated reasons for this
conflict and um no one's innocent no
one's innocent
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Julian
who says the cat sport dagger is
lightbringer it makes too much sense as
a classic George Martin twist everyone's
expecting Dawn or something but turns
out to be this little dagger what if the
catsport dagger is Like A Shard of the
original lightbringer like we know that
Valerian steel can be melted down like
ice is melted down into oath keeper and
widow's whale so maybe catspaw is like a
piece of the original lightbringer that
would be cool
Tanya says can dragons go to war without
a rider Dany went around everywhere with
three of hers can a writer not claim
more than one
yeah so
in the books Daenerys is is bonded to
drogon like drogon is the only dragon
that Daenerys rides um and in the show
like viserion and rhaegar seem to like
follow daenerys's lead and
um and follow her orders but like
the books not so much like it it's it's
not super clear exactly how the dragon
connection works but a dragon rider can
only claim one Dragon for life
um as far as we know
um and we do see dragons in war without
Riders sometimes but they're not really
controllable like you kind of need a
rider in order to control a dragon and
as we saw this episode even when you do
have a rider on a dragon sometimes they
are still not controllable so so yeah I
mean it could be an option to let loose
some dragons that don't have Riders but
that might be a very dangerous thing to
do
um there's no guarantee that the dragon
is going to attack who you want them to
attack
if they don't have a rider but yeah
those that's a good there are those are
the questions are all going to be
relevant as The Story Goes On
uh red salt Compares Vega burning Dawn
to the U.S invasion of Iraq uh jarek
asks are the green and black parents
sharpening their kids claws to fight in
the pits of War Ah that's a great Point
jarek yeah so I mean you know this is
the show's all about the parents pushing
their kids into the parents conflict
um and how messed up that is and yeah
that's a great point that just as those
children in those slave fighting pits
were being pushed in to fight each other
and armed and prepared to fight each
other
uh in a way these Noble Royal parents
are doing the same thing with Jace and
Luke and Joff and with aegon a name and
they're sharpening their teeth by giving
them swords and giving them dragons and
they're pushing them into the fighting
pit by by you know pitting them against
each other in this conflict so yeah it's
a great Point Derek I think those child
fighting pits can be seen as an analogy
for this this whole conflict writ large
um Abyssal says seeing Vega should be a
sign to quickly nope out yeah when Luke
first arrived at Storm's end and saw
Vega already at Storm's end good time to
run away for sure but you know Luke was
trying to be brave and you know in this
world like you know reputation is so
much like people would have mocked him
if he like turned up but then turned
tail if he just ran away uh and you know
he he had been entrusted with this
Mission by his mother so he tried to saw
it through tried to see it through and
he and he died for it
thanks for the Super Chat from
Christopher who says the Storm at
Storm's end was beautiful
yeah I thought it looked lovely a
similar storm in in Stormbreaker Bay as
it's called Uh killed Robert Renly and
Stannis baratheon's parents
um Stefan Baratheon and um what's her
name uh Turtle lady who who died in a
storm while they were coming in on a
ship so there's a long history of those
storms and storms causing a raucus
uh we've talked about how
in the books uh it appears that aemond
was in control of his dragon in the
books
um Rachel says have we talked about
demon choking rhaenyra we have
um I think that
I think that it's pretty consistent I
think that Daemon has hurt innocent
people
a lot of times
um when he's feeling emotional and so
I'm not shocked that he's violent to his
wife he has always been a [ __ ]
um
you know I mean he he's been horrible to
viserys as well in the past
um I don't like we've been told that
demon has no limit Alison said Daemon
has no limit and I think that she's
correct Daemon when he's emotional uh he
hurts people and that's what happens
here and he's and he's in a particularly
emotional state with the death of
viserys and with you know Alison
crowning aegon and so on so yeah
daemon's not a good guy
JW says I'm not convinced that this show
needed to be made never did it actually
come close to the vast and impactful
story I was reading in Fire and Blood
um yeah well your mileage may vary I
like House of the Dragon more than I
like Fire and Blood Fire and Blood is is
a very sparse plot summary whereas Hot D
has has all the detail and and the drama
and the emotion and the dialogue
um and you know you might imagine
um your own idea of the details from
Reading Fire and Blood I mean that
that's part of what Fire and Blood does
is that it it Sparks your imagination
like it it just gives you a vague idea
of what happened and then you have to
imagine the details in Fire and Blood
so I mean it's apples and oranges really
like Fire and Blood and House of the
Dragon are just two very different
things it's amazing our house house of
the Dragon is very faithful to Fire and
Blood like very like like mostly House
of the Dragon does not contradict Fire
and Blood except for a few important
details
um and it's interesting how it manages
to be so faithful but also manages to
sort of diverge and and deepen it in a
lot of ways
thanks for the Super Chat from Pedro who
says Daemon losing his losing his temper
and strangling rhaenyra reminded me of
Awakening the dragon and Danny's brother
viserys how common are these impulse
control issues in male targaryens
yeah
um that's a good point uh viserys was
was horrible and violent towards his
sister Daenerys and yeah it is pretty
common among targaryens I mean I'm
reminded of Arion Targaryen
um
who was a very unpleasant Targaryen
Prince
um who ended up going mad and drinking
wildfire in the belief that it would
transform him into a dragon but uh yeah
there are a lot of examples of
targaryens who are
violent and delusional and and hurt the
people around them
um the idea of Targaryen Madness comes
up a lot and um we could debate all day
if Daemon is going mad is that something
that could happen oh
uh so yeah it's not uncommon and I mean
you know we can attribute that partly to
the blood of the Dragon that's in them
the fire in their blood we can attribute
that to the uh generations of incest
uh maybe scrambling their brains a bit
we can attribute that also to just too
much power in one man's hands like
making someone a prince I mean what does
that do to your ego what does that do to
your moral compass
um
sometimes princes are dicks because they
have too much power and too much ego so
I think all of those things contribute
um but also you know that of course it
comes down to personal responsibility
and personal choices and um sometimes
Daemon makes really bad ones
thanks for the Super Chat from Sasha oh
we did that one
um we talked about that one
and
Jal says y'all says I feel like Daemon
choking rhaenyra is similar to laris's
fate thing because it shows the power
they hold over the Queens
yeah I mean I guess I guess you could
say that like you know no matter how
powerful these women are
um the men in their life are still
stronger than them and there's just like
an inherent power imbalance between men
and women regardless of what their
titles are and regardless of what their
hierarchies are so that's an element as
well I suppose
thanks for the Super Chat from late and
from Taylor who says this stream has
become part of my Sunday schedule we'll
miss it and this community thank you for
your work and insight thank you Taylor
I'm very grateful for all of you coming
and joining in every week this has been
really fun uh I think we're going to
wrap this stream up shortly
um
I'll go and try and answer as many of
your questions as I can before we wrap
it up
um but yeah it's been a pleasure thank
you everybody for the support
um thanks so much for watching
um it's been fun I'm I'm glad the show
was good
it's not a perfect show but but uh it's
it's given us a lot to talk about and a
lot to think about and um looking
forward to making more House of the
dragon as it comes out and more Game of
Thrones and song of Earth and fire stuff
and uh yeah it's been real all right
we'll uh try and answer
um your questions and then we'll wrap it
up pretty shortly
John says
maybe the dragon's influence the writers
yeah I mean one question for me is like
what exactly was viserys's relationship
to balerion like we keep seeing
valerion's skull in hot day and we've
seen viserys you know gazing up at
balerion while he's talking about how
dragons are dangerous and can't be
controlled so it sounds like you know
maybe viserys had a bad experience with
valerion and maybe viserys you know
failed to control valerion and that
makes sense you know like it seems as
though Vega is hard for aemond to
control because vegar is so old and
powerful and and strong-willed so you
know balerion was even bigger and even
older and even stronger so you know and
viserys was young at the time so maybe
something really scary happened to
viserys when he was riding valerion it
would be cool if we find out about it
like maybe viserys told Daemon and maybe
Daemon could reveal this in a later
season like oh yeah viserys told me he
flew balerion and he almost died you
know like valerion almost killed someone
like whoa it was a really traumatic
moment that would be cool
and yeah maybe dragons influence their
Riders like maybe viserys was scared
because you know in some kind of psychic
connection that may or may not exist
between the dragons and the writers
maybe Daemon sorry maybe viseris sensed
all of the death and destruction the
balerion has caused all of the Wars all
the battles all of the horror all of the
charred corpses and maybe that just
freaked vasaris out and he's like I
don't want any part of this you know
so yeah those are all valid questions
Jack says what is aegon's opinion of
rhaenyra well previously I mean we saw
aegon say to Alison like oh like what
what kind of brother would I be if I
stole Rainier's Throne he says something
like that in in this scene and in the
books
um and in the books like yeah like like
aegon really needs some convincing to
accept the crown partly because he he
doesn't think it's right for him to
steal Rainier's Throne so so yeah like
aegon does not hate rhaenyra like we
don't see much of a relationship between
them but I think that's part of the
tragedy of this whole conflict is that
the Rival claimants they don't even hate
each other like aegon and Arena don't
even hate each other but they are the
figureheads in this conflict that is
really more about Hightower ambition and
Targaryen ambition and and all these
other issues so um yeah it'll be I mean
that's the other thing like like if
Allison and rhaenyra just sat down and
had a conversation or if aegon and
Rainier just sat down and had a
conversation maybe they could sort it
out although I think at this point like
now that they have crowned aegon and now
that aegon has experienced the joys of
of the adulation of the common folk I
think that aegon does not want to let go
of the crown now I think it might be too
late at this point because once you put
a crown on a beast you can't uncrown him
one-eyed Crow says that Otto arrives on
Dragonstone under a three-headed Green
Dragon not golden yeah so in the books
aegon uses a golden dragon sigil to
distinguish himself from the red
Targaryen Dragon used by rhaenyra and
yeah it's interesting that they
mentioned a green dragon
um in this episode which I think makes
sense I mean
who have called aegon and Allison's
faction the greens so I think it would
be confusing to viewers if the greens
used a yellow dragon you know so
um so I I would I I think it makes sense
if the greens use a green dragon I think
that's fine
um I'm interested if they are ever going
to call Rainier's side the blacks
um because rhaenyra's side is called the
blacks in the books but they've never
actually said that in the show so far I
wonder if they might change them to the
to the reds or something
um because I wonder if they might be uh
worried that people might hear the
blacks and get the wrong impression
about what that means so yeah I don't
know but uh it'll be something to sort
out in season two
Frankie says why is Vegas so ugly why
are you so ugly Frankie Macy says seems
like the dragons can just sort their own
beef ignoring their Riders is this in
the books it's not not really no it's
not really in the books I mean dragons
are hard to control like and if a dragon
is pissed off it will attack people like
I mean yeah dragons can act
independently yes
um but we've never quite seen something
like this with like you know aemon
failing to control Vega and Vega are
just murking Luke like we haven't seen
that in um we haven't seen that in the
books but it's plausible it's plausible
within the law
uh we've talked about that Robbie says
bar Emin is an odd name even by Westeros
standards what's up with that yeah it
mentioned House Bar Emin which is a
Crown's crownlands
um
house
and yeah I don't know what the etymology
is there are a bunch of like kooky names
for houses which sometimes are
references to silly things
um like there's I think house Jordan of
the tour
yeah here's the tour ruled by house
Jordan
um which is a reference to
um an author who was published by Tor
publishing like George just named the
house after one of his author buddies
and a publishing company that he likes
um and there's a bunch of other examples
like there's like characters named after
uh football players
um there's
Jordan is is named after an author uh
there's a lot of there's a lot of funny
little references in the house names and
stuff sometimes I mean there's also it
has also a Donald Trump reference in
Fire and Blood actually
um
so like in the book when they're
describing the coronation of aegon they
talk about oh you know the dragon pit
had seating for you know this many
thousands of people uh and the number of
people who attended the coronation is a
matter of some dispute this maester says
that 10 000 people came but this other
person says that 50 000 people came to
the coronation
um which appears to be a reference to
the
um
talk about different numbers of people
who attended the inauguration of Donald
Trump in 2016. so George Martin made a
reference to that uh in Fire and Blood
it appears which uh yeah
thanks George
thanks for the Super Chat from Red who
says weird question but any idea what
the greyjoys are up to the greyjoys are
up to Classic graduate [ __ ] basically
um they are currently ruled by uh Lord
Dalton Greyjoy who is called the red
Kraken uh because he sheds a lot of
blood so
um yeah the greyjoys have been shedding
some blood and they may see an
opportunity for more Bloodshed in this
conflict so it will be cool to see how
the greyjoys get involved in season two
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Richard who says whenever they announce
the king or queen they mentioned the
royna why Dawn hasn't joined the Seven
Kingdoms yet yeah it's true but I think
that's something that aegon did ever
since he landed was he has been
declaring himself the king of the
continent uh Because he believes in uh
what's it called he believes in
manifesting his desires you know if you
say so if you say that you want a thing
to be true enough it'll become true no
um
yeah they they want Dawn to be part of
the realm so they sort of act as though
it is even though it's not I think
that's basically the answer
um thanks to the Super Chat from Hunter
and from
Raya and from cat
who says Vega makes amond genetically
Stronger by Magic compared to aegon
uh sure
Dylan says are you okay with all of the
changes from the books I I don't like
the fact that Alison misunderstood
viserys's words and thinks that viserys
wanted aegon to be king I I don't like
that very much because it makes like a
random misunderstanding coincidence one
of the major causes of the conflict and
I don't like that so much I prefer when
it's like
decisions made by characters as opposed
to Accidental misunderstandings driving
the story
and I still am not like super on board
with like aegon's prophecy about the
white walkers being Central to this
conflict
um
because I like it more when it's more
about like personal human ambition
personal human emotions driving the
story rather than highfalutin White
Walker nonsense but I guess you know
that prophecy stuff is okay to the
extent that it focuses more on the
responsibility to be a good king and the
responsibility to rule the realm well
and I think that's I think that's really
what viserys is talking about when he
talks about the prophecy because they
never actually say white walkers in hot
day they've only said oh there'll be a
cold wind from the north and we must
unite against the common enemy and it's
like okay like you can see it more as a
metaphor for let's not be [ __ ] you know
and that I can respect
Mort says if amond didn't kill Luke do
you think rhaenyra would have considered
Otto's offer for the good of the realm I
think that's a good question and I think
maybe she would because yeah like
Rainier did say like I'll give you your
answer on the morrow you know like
Rainier did not spit in Otto's face and
say no I'm we're gonna fight a war for
the throne [ __ ] you no she said oh think
about it so you know but before she
could give her answer she found out that
Luke was killed and and now it looks
like she's on a war path so so yeah I
mean maybe tragically uh it would have
been okay if it wasn't for that death if
it wasn't for bloody Vega wanting a
snack maybe this conflict could have
ended but I mean you know that that's
true of so many events in this story
there have been so many moments that if
they went differently uh things could
have been okay and I think that's that's
the the tragedy of it
uh gonna says that uh Extreme Ways by
Moby plays in the background when
Rainier receives this news
uh midnight says do you think a
blackfyre rebellion TV series would work
or is it more difficult than the dance
of the Dragons oh well I mean there are
no dragons in the blackfyre Rebellion so
that means that the CGI High budget
would be significantly cheaper
um I I think that the issue with the
blackfyre show is that
the Duncan egg books are not finished
yet and the Duncan egg books uh are
meant to cover that time period but
George has only written three of the
10-ish stories that he intends to write
so
um I think that the blackfyre rebellions
could be really cool but I think that
George should finish the books first
snagged says does rhaenyra think her
being Queen is worth a war yeah well I
think that that is what she is thinking
about all throughout this episode
um and her hope is to be Queen without
fighting a war that's what she wants
um and I it's interesting throughout
this episode how you know Daemon and the
men are plotting war and she's trying to
pull back from war so yeah like I I
don't think Rainier wants thousands of
people to die in order for her to get
the throne
um
I think she might give up her crown if
it meant averting a war if it was that
simple but I think that it's not that
simple and I think that now that Luke is
dead her feelings are going to change
and she's going to be angrier
coopy says do you think amond will tell
everyone that he didn't mean to kill
luceris or will he act like he meant to
I think he will act like he meant to
Lotus says do you think how Valyrian
steel is found from the old age could
they use a dragon horn yeah ancient
Valyrian Dragon hordes horns were used
to control dragons in the past
apparently
um and euron finds a dragon horn in the
Game of Thrones books apparently
um so yeah I mean it's it's conceivable
it's conceivable that they might find a
dragon horn in Hot D and use it to
control dragons better since they do
have trouble controlling dragons I mean
euron claims that Dragon binder can
steal daenerys's dragons so so you know
the greens they are outnumbered Dragon
wise so if the greens uh took some of
the blacks dragons then they could uh
even the playing field
but uh yeah the books don't mention any
such thing Nicole says why did Rainier
think that Daemon knew about the Song of
Ice and Fire yeah I thought that was a
little weird
um like viserys said that like this is
passed down from King to air like he was
but but I mean well that's the thing
like Daemon was
um viserys's heir until the birth of
rangnero
uh but viserys chose not to tell Daemon
so yeah maybe Rainier assumed that since
Daemon was viserys's Heir before
rhaenyra was born then maybe she assumed
that Daemon must know but it's weird
that you know
rhaenyra has known about this for years
and she never brought it up with Daemon
she just assumed that he'd already knew
like like what that's kind of weird
that's kind of weird the way that they
framed that but but I think that they
framed it in such a way to highlight the
shock and betrayal that Daemon feels to
find that his brother fazerus didn't
trust him
Sasha says that the change making Alison
misunderstand viserys's wishes is a way
to make her less villainous yeah I think
that one of the the biggest changes that
they've made compared to the books is
that they have made Rainier and Alison
much more peaceful much more sympathetic
compared to in the books but I imagine
that might change as The Story Goes On
uh I I think that you know this whole
season has really been an origin story
this whole season has really been a
prologue
um this is just setting the table and
this is just introducing us to the
characters and showing us why they feel
the way they feel you know explaining
their relationships explaining their
history so that when the [ __ ] hits the
fan we will
um fully understand the weight of it
thanks no face and Travis Travis says
what is your biggest letdown of the
season
um
um
that's an interesting question I I mean
I disliked it when Daemon did his like
solo mission in the stepstones and he
like dodged all those arrows and like it
it really felt like uh it really felt
like a Game of Thrones season season
seven season eight type thing like I
don't like the violence when it feels
silly and like unrealistic like he
killed so many people and dodged so many
arrows and it's like okay like
the story the violence has no weight if
the characters have plot armor you know
so I did not enjoy that very much
um
and you'll have mixed feelings about
some of the changes but yeah I don't
know I'll have to think about it
um I think that we're going to wrap up
this stream I'm sorry that I haven't
answered all of your
questions uh but I've been talking for a
few hours so it's time to wrap it up
guys
thank you so much
for being a part of this
um maybe we will do another live stream
in a week or two just to sort of
consolidate any more thoughts that we
have there will be the explained video
the season one episode 10 explained
video will come out I I think in a
couple of weeks or a few weeks we might
take a bit more time for this next
explained video
just to get it right doing the weekly
schedule is
um nuts it is in fact cuckoo bananas to
make a 25 to 30 minute video essay every
week so um I think we will take a little
bit more time with this finale video
um and then we'll take a break and then
afterwards we will get back to making
some Song of Ice and Fire videos making
some Dune videos
the uh patreon supporters voted for a
Jon Snow video
called the real Jon Snow it's going to
be similar to the real Tyrion Lannister
video that we made all about Jon Snow in
the books and how it's different to Jon
Snow in the show and I think that video
is going to be really cool we're also
going to make more Dune videos uh the
philosophy of Dune about like the themes
and ideas of June that'll be really cool
when the second Dune movie comes out
we're gonna do a real June part 2 video
that's the plan
so there will be much more stuff coming
and it wouldn't be possible without your
support so thank you all so much for
watching uh and supporting and to the
patrons and to the super chats uh you
make it possible
so in the meantime
um the next explained video will be a
few weeks away so in the meantime you
might like to check out some other house
of the Dragon Game of Thrones people
um radio Westeros is really good history
of Westeros
the nodacast podcast Gladys Joe magician
gray area Tony Teflon in deep geek
there's a million really good channels
that you should check out and you should
support
I want to thank Schubert reads for
moderating the live chat I know that has
not been an easy job you might like to
check out uh Schubert reads
YouTube channel for some readings of
cool stuff
you might like to
um you might like to check out the alt
ship Z Channel which has like readings
of stuff you might like to follow the
old chip decks podcast on Spotify you
can get all of these live streams as
audio feeds you can also get the alt
shift x videos in an audio feed links in
the description
thank you for everyone supporting on
patreon we're going to get back to the
usual patreon uh early video access and
the monthly Patron only live stream and
all that good stuff after we get back
from a break and uh there's gonna be
lots of cool more stuff coming in
ah what else should we say is there
anything else to say I think we're done
uh it's been great thank you
till next time